any
>> we are looking at that Azir deck list
one more time we've seen him before but
we're seeing it again it was a fantastic
list that we've seen work to perfection
it's all about timing all about those
gear and it's all about managing
resources not units now
>> I think we've certainly had enough time
for production to make that sand counter
at this point right
>> yeah come on guys
>> I know it's not a real thing anyway
Okay, we've got Brismat's
Annie deck here. We see the Rex Eye. We
see the Rengar. I mean, cards that we
haven't necessarily, we certainly have
not seen in the limelight, but they work
so well with Annie being such a hyper
aggressive deck. And Rengar working
particularly good with Annie because you
can effectively play it for one energy
and one power if you're able to use that
extra energy on your turn and ready
those runes with Annie. So, very, very
strong deck. looks reminiscent of course
of the mid-range Draven but with a lot
of additional and different tools that
people are just not ready for because
it's Annie
>> bringing the unexpected can be such a
powerful utilization in this game and
we're absolutely seeing that right now.
>> Absolutely. I mean it is running so many
true drops. It's running the Noxis
hopefuls. It's of course got stacked
deck rebukes. I mean, it has all of that
interaction that you would expect to see
in a Chaos Fury deck, but it also has,
you know, I think the number of times
that I saw in scrims and in testing
Prismat play that Rengar and people
like, "Oh, yeah, that's right. There's
just a there's just a plus five that can
come out of nowhere. I forgot about
that. I know that now."
that just gave many wins that people
just weren't expecting because I can
play around and a plus two or I'm not
playing around
with that also has a body there. It's
just such a good card. Also, don't
bother rebuking the Rengar cuz it will
come right back down.
>> Rengar pouncing is quite right.
>> Absolutely.
>> The name is very apt. when you are
unprepared, it will pounce. And
unfortunately, that clearly has happened
a lot in this event. And we saw it
earlier today, and I'm sure we might get
a chance to see it again.
>> Yeah, I mean, we even saw it in the
little clips. We saw it in the little
clips right before this the the the
clips of Prismat's game where setting up
these combats where they have a lot of
energy up and usually that's that's a
reelious game plan to have a lot of
energy up and have these combat tricks
and and he's like no I've got a bunch as
well. I've got long sword. I've got I've
got hard bargain. I've got Rengar. got
all of these cards that are just so so
good and are able to be played in combat
in a in a deck that's not usually doing
a lot of combat manipulation like that.
Not anymore. It used to have fighter
flights. It's it does have rebuke, but
that it's not the same, right? You're
not expecting that angle of attack like
Rengar and like Cleave can because that
kind of fell out of favor a lot.
>> Yeah. And I think that's the thing.
these are these unforgotten cards gone
by that actually are still really
powerful and you know in this instance
this Annie Aggro deck isn't going to
have the surprise element as much
>> as we've known before because obviously
um Patre is going to know what's in this
deck this time round. So actually they
do have that opportunity to look at the
deck lists. So they are going to know
what could come up. But it's all well
and good seeing something written on a
page. But do you remember what it does?
Because I don't know about you guys, but
I have a poor memory and I do not
remember the differences between the
different Rengar cards. Like I wouldn't
know off the top of my head if I was
reading it just on a piece of paper
because it had been that long before
this event before I was like, "Oh my
gosh, look at this Annie list. Wowza."
>> I didn't remember what it did. I'm going
to be honest.
>> Yeah. Well, no. And it it really hasn't
seen a lot of play. Even though it's a
Spear Forge card, it has not seen a ton
of play. I think a lot of people have
looked at it and considered it. And it
is a really cool card. We did see it
played a little bit in China, but
honestly, not much outside of that. And
there's just it's not necessarily
hitting the break points or is efficient
enough to be played in a lot of decks.
But Annie, it makes so much sense. You
can spend your energy on your turn. As
long as you have one left up, you'll
ready two runes. And that's three.
Rengar is a reaction. You can play it on
your opponent's turn and you're
effectively gaining that extra two
energy and you can actually put it into
stats that impact the board that is
really, really strong.
>> As if Annie didn't need another excuse
to be more aggressive with their play
style. And here we are giving them
another good reason to be. And I'm
honestly pleasantly surprised by this
deck list. But I'm also
>> uh I'm also surprised I'm surprised I
haven't seen this before. I'm surprised
this took me by surprise and I'm happy
about it. I got to say I'm really
excited to see how this matchup plays
out because I haven't seen this Annie
before now.
>> I haven't seen how it might interact
with Sea.
>> Is it aggressive enough to deal with
that many units? Because although we
have lots of aggression, we have lots of
ways to defeat, we're equally going up
against a potentially lots of sand
soldiers which have adaptable stance,
>> right? Yeah. And certainly this is a
matchup that
I if I didn't know Prismat personally
and didn't know just how extensive their
testing can be, I would say probably
both of these players have not played
against this their respective matchups
very much. However, I do know Prismat
and I do know how extensive their
testing is. I would almost guarantee
that they have reps into Azir. Now, was
it a player of Pedro's caliber playing
Azir? Was it their build? I mean, almost
impossible to say.
>> So,
>> they do get like you said, it's one
thing seeing it on a piece of paper,
it's another thing seeing it in the
hands of a top four level competitor.
So, I mean, at the end of the day, it's
going to come down to their
fundamentals. It's going to come down to
what preparation they've had. Obviously,
both of these players have played
absolutely spectacularly so far. They've
both got best of metal cards that they
can take home regardless, but they want
to win. I know Prismat. I've known
Prismat for a long time across many
games. Prismat does not care about
constellation prizes. Prismat was bummed
when they were handed the best of
Draven. I know this for a fact. We were
talking about it backstage. They were
bummed when they were handed the best of
driven because they had just lost in the
top eight. This means everything to both
of these players as we are getting into
our top four. Prismaticism on the Annie
Pedro on the Azir.
>> They're just having a last little look
at those lists. An important time for
both of them trying to remember what
counts are in each other's decks so that
they can play around them. And this is
another skill in and of itself that we
don't get a lot of time to practice
quite often.
>> Yeah, absolutely. It is uh yeah, you
don't really have to prep open deck list
a lot because unless you're top eighting
in RQ or above, you're probably not
playing open deck list. However, it is a
very important thing to do when you are
at that point. But we're jumping on into
game number one. Hall of Legends on the
side of Pedro. The seat of power over
for Annie. Now we saw seed of power
actually on the side of both players. So
this is one that is certainly going to
benefit Pedro as well.
>> Let's see if we get set up in the way
that we want. Going for those mulligans
incredibly important to Mulligan if you
don't have the ideal start. We can
mulligan up to two cards. And yep. Well,
Azir doing what Azir does best. We've
made a gear and a sand soldier on your
first turn. I say that's pretty good.
>> Yep, that's the way you want to do it
for sure. Get those sand soldiers ready
to roll. And of course, being able to
get that initial tempo going, get that
might on the board, get those
battlefields conquered where you need,
especially with the seed of power cuz if
you're able to start conquering faster,
you're going to be able to draw those
extra cards. This is a, you know, this
has certainly been a reveal party for
seed of power. I think I don't know if I
saw the card played very much at all
before this event, but with the opening
up of Battlefields, we've seen such a
diversity.
>> And honestly, I'm all for it. I don't
know about you, but I'm so pleased that
we've been able to see diversity in the
battlefields that everyone's choosing.
And obviously, there there are a lot
more out there than I think a lot of
people give them credit for. There's a
lot that kind of they have this
reputation for being good and or bad,
but actually I think that a lot more
have uh kind of potential, more
potential than we think.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And there's certainly
ones that I think we're still as a
community really figuring out the really
the formula for how to utilize
Battlefields best. There's a lot that
are that are definitely more playable
than we think, but it's also, you know,
how are we actually choosing to use
these battlefields? Do we have one that
we always lead on? Do we have one that
we use when we go first? Do we have one
that we use when we go second? That was
sort of my basic playbook for how I
started to understand choosing
battlefields. But I think that there it
even goes matchup to matchup. Like it's
this is my lead against this deck. This
is my going first if XYZ has happened.
So, I think there is a lot there's a
absolutely massive amount that can go
into Battlefield Choice and uh really
we're just beginning to scratch the
surface of it.
>> Absolutely. You're absolutely correct.
That is the the be all and end all
really is that battlefields are strong,
but are they going to benefit our
opponent too much? In this instance,
both battlefields are good for both
players. So, I'd say that's pretty even.
Our stack deck choice has been made and
we've been able to once again cherrypick
a Nox as hopeful and we get that nice
Legion effect so it only costs two.
>> Yeah, one of the uh really one of the
best starts that you can have as Annie
that stack deck as a one cost card. Of
course, that Nox Hopeful being the most
amount of might that you can get for two
energy for the most part at least out of
a single card right now. So, you really
want to have that to be able to contest
what Azir is going to be doing here. We
got another gear. We got another sand
soldier. Azir doing what Azia does best.
And now we're going to be looking at
whether it's worthwhile dipping our toe
into the Hall of Legends, which it is.
You can actually uh when you conquer
there, you can pay one to ready the
legend and then you can jump back out if
you want to be safe. Um which is I
really like that effect for uh for Pedro
here. So it feels pretty strong. Yeah,
if you're able to actually uh have the
energy for it, you can make two sand
soldiers on a turn if you've played a
gear there. But obviously did not have
the energy to do it in this case. But
now Prismat going to see are they going
to go for that open battlefield or are
they going to try to contest? Nope, just
going to take the seed of power there.
Go for that first point and take it from
there.
Got to try and keep toe in toe. The
pressure is on. Kaiser is coming in. Is
she accelerated? Yeah. Oh no. No. We're
just being
>> accelerated. Just play to the
battlefield. Yeah.
>> Yeah. In with that is hopeful.
>> These are the types of things where, you
know, if I picked up this deck and just
played it without talking or testing,
the chances I make that play are near
zero. And maybe that's a reflection of
me, but the my brain does not function
in the way that I'm thinking, oh, I want
to play this defensive Kai'Sa on a
battlefield without accelerating it and
not drawing a card. That is just
practice and knowing the matchup,
knowing the deck at such a level. And
that's what Prismaticism is doing here.
>> Prismaticism has been through every
single scenario. And you can tell this
is top level play. They know exactly
what they're doing. They know what
exactly what they're doing into Pedro's
deck and they're making this big
defensive wall on this one battlefield
for hopefully some consistent hold
points.
>> Absolutely protect that seed of power.
You know, you don't want Azir to be
drawing a bunch of cards. That is really
not a place you want to be. And oh,
>> the aggressive hold Annie deck. Is this
what is this the world that we're living
in right now? It looks like it might
just be as the fairest forerunner comes
down and is really defending that seat
of power or at least allowing the Kaiser
to potentially back out here.
>> 14 currently on that seat of power. They
want that seat. That's their seat.
>> This is where I'm sitting.
>> No one else will take it from me. My
ferris warrunner Kaiser and Oxus hopeful
say so. And for at least now, everyone
is staying in there, making sure that
we're building that right up. No sand
soldiers are going to be able to touch
that in a while.
>> And Prismat really just deciding whether
or not they want to move the Kaiso. They
say no, we're going to ready the two
runes there and pass it back over to
Pedro who is got a nice little uh nice
little sand soldier army down there.
Three equipment in play. A lot of energy
as well and three points to boob.
>> And here we go. We're starting the frey.
First sand soldier goes to challenge
that seat of power. Going to just trade
with the Kaiser. Obviously the BF sword
goes back into base. We get to keep that
around. And that's a nice thing about
these sand soldiers is that they're
expendable. You can just throw them into
a situation to allow yourselves to
soften up the aggression from your
opponent.
>> Absolutely. you're able to, you know,
especially when you can cascade these
equipment, that really gets to be a
strong play. And there we go. Desert's
call. That's not one, but two more sand
soldiers coming in with Bladem if you so
choose.
>> Ring ring. Who's there? Desert's
calling.
And Prismat is trying to put them on
hold, but unfortunately not something
that they're able to do. Just allowing
those sand soldiers to
come into play in the backline and uh
pick up a piece of equipment if they so
desire.
>> And adding another one into Hall of
Legends.
Just adding extras in there. Kind of
feels like they've both gone, "No, I
want this one. I want this one." are
sharing right now, which isn't really
what we do in Riftban. We don't we don't
share the battlefield. So, uh, at some
point we're going to have to start
making some aggressive plays. Who will
be the aggressor? You naturally would
think Annie. So, we have hidden a card
there for Pedro.
>> Yeah, this is the the really funny thing
that can happen when in high level
where, you know, both players are are
trying to jockey for position. They're
trying to not overcommit and the game
really slows down for both players where
oh, I don't really want to conquer. I'm
giving my opponent enough credit here to
not uh to to have an answer. So, I'm
going to just I'm just going to set up
here. I'm going to hold. Pedro says this
is fine. I'm technically ahead on point
tempo right now. If we just keep passing
the turn, I'm going to win before you
are. So, you need to do something first.
>> Exactly. You're forcing your opponent's
hand. You've got to at some point you
there has to be more than this. You
can't just carry on with this pace of us
sharing these battlefields. But for now,
we're going to continue building that
wall. Kais is in base and booting it
back over to Pedro.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, both players really just Okay,
how much might I get into play without
spending any power? How many resources
can I develop to have at my disposal
when the ultimate turn happens that we
need to make that that first move?
>> It's going to be an explosive showdown.
>> It's going to be a crazy It's almost
certainly going to be an absolutely
crazy turn when that happens because you
know both players I think see the
writing on the wall. We're going to keep
passing. No player sees a good
opportunity necessarily. Maybe I speak
too soon. And a sand soldier is going
in. That is an onguard as well.
>> Okay.
>> To try to get some material off of the
board of Prismat.
>> Is this just an attempt at softening up
that battlefield again or are we going
all the way? That's what Prismaticism is
going to be thinking about in whether
they try any tricks to keep all of their
units around or whether they just kind
of let the Azia just soften this up a
little bit with the sand soldier. But it
looks like we're considering jumping
back at that defy.
Is it worth the resources? That's the
that begs the question. Yeah, it's it's
really what is your endgame plan here?
What are you trying to do here? We do
see a flash on the side of Prismat. They
may want to get their non Forrunner
units out of the out of harm's way.
Trade the first half of 4Runner for a
sand soldier, get the two mechs, go from
there. Or, you know, they may just say,
"Okay, let this happen. You know, let
Pedro take out a couple of these units
and then see what happens from there."
But looks like we may be committing a
card here.
>> We're 7 to 12 power currently on seat of
power.
>> The pressure is intense.
>> Yeah, I was I was the the might trackers
are amazing, but only if you look at the
right one. I was looking at the Hall of
Legends. So actually, yes, this this
flash potentially could just be getting
the could just be getting two units out
and just throwing away, not even killing
a sand soldier, which is going to cause
a conquer point up to five, which is
going to draw a card from the seed of
power. So these are all things that are
being considered right now by Prismat.
And the implications of any one of these
plays needs to be thought of.
>> That's the problem. The damage is too
much. So actually it does then become a
problem. So we are going to go for the
flash.
Seeing if Pedra has an answer or whether
yeah we're going to bring the Nox as
hopeful.
>> Okay looks like chose to flash just the
>> We're going to on guard again just to
take out both but we will get the two
mech tokens and Pedro goes up to five
points from the conquer. Yeah, that is a
conquer. That's going to be a draw from
the seat of power. But now we do have
quite a bit of might in the backline for
Prismat here. So they're going to be
able to put forth at least somewhat of
an attack. We'll see what they're able
to do.
>> Pedro managing to poke through all of
those huge units just using a single
sand soldier is incredibly impressive.
Going for another Desert's Call here.
But we've got so many guys on that speed
dial. Just getting another couple of
sand soldiers in on this one in base and
one there at the seat of power. Doesn't
really want to allow prismaticism to
take that back with ease. So at least
going to present a bit of a tussle by
allowing some sand soldiers to remain on
there. Currently at what three six is at
nine power on there at the moment. We're
moving a gear across. Going to bump that
up even more. Trying to keep it kind of
level on both of the battlefields here,
which begs the question kind of which
one does Prismaticism start to try to
buckle first.
>> Yeah, it's certainly going to be tough.
And one key difference here between
Draven and Annie is that Azir is able to
make these combats happen. And even if
they happen to lose a combat, lose a
sand soldier, they're at least not
feeding a card over to the Annie, but we
are of course so we are of course seeing
Prismat with only a few cards in hand
even though they've won a few combats
here. Going to have to try to make
something happen as there is a lot of
might on the side of the Azir. Not only
is there a lot of might, there's gear,
physical units, the bodies on the board
right now are in the troves. They truly
have made a sand soldier army to present
against the aggression that an Annie
deck presents. And now Prismaticism is
in a position where they're going to
have to split their units potentially
because their deck doesn't have a lot of
versatility when it comes to kind of
being able to gank or being able to move
from battlefield to battlefield. So we
might have to chip away at these
separately. And then there's those pesky
hidden cards. And obviously they've seen
the deck list. They probably know what's
coming. But it's also just sometimes a
bit of a mind game.
Yeah, absolutely. The thing is is that
they can be at least it could be hidden
blade. It could also be guards.
This is also a hidden card. And yes,
again does have the exclamation mark in
the text. So I am legally obliged to
yell it like that. It's it's just the
rules.
>> It's true. We checked while we were
backstage. So
>> we checked with the legal team and they
said the police were on their way if I
didn't scream it. So sorry folks, has to
happen.
So, it's just about whether he can
dismantle this board. There's a lot of
thinking going on and honestly, I
respect it because this are this is
crunch time. These are the moments that
really matter and this is what sets our
players apart from everyone else. They
are just anticipating every possible
scenario. They're going through it.
They're running through the stats in
their head. They're doing the math on
this board. We have little trackers.
They don't. They got to do it in their
heads. I wouldn't I'd be looking at this
going, "Where do I even start?"
>> Right. Well, Prismat says, "I am going
to start with an Annie from the Chosen
Champ Zone and into a stacked deck."
>> Annie stubborn. She's a familiar face
and not one that we love to see to be
honest because she can be rather a big
nuisance.
>> Yeah, she's going to be able to get a
stacked deck back.
I imagine
we did we did cast the stack deck. Not
sure what was off of the top. Maybe a
cleave. Looks like it was a cleave.
>> Yeah, looks like it.
>> So, that's going to help.
>> Yeah, we've got a Rengar and a cleave.
That is threatening up to eight here.
Now, how does that change the math?
Because it's not just eight coming in at
once. It can be staggered. It can be
across multiple battlefields. It can be
across multiple combats potentially. So
really, Prismat is figuring out what is
the best way to make it as awkward as
possible for for Pedro to do these
blocks here.
>> Right, we're cleaving on our mechs and
we're going to just poke away at that
seat of power to begin with. See if
Pedro has any reaction. See if we're
going to play that hidden card. And it's
okay. It's hidden blade on their own
unit here.
>> Oo, okay. We saw that before. We've seen
it in uh we've seen it in combat before.
We've seen it again. It's a great
utilization of being able to take out
your own unit so you can draw some cards
and that's just going to help in these
combat situations. Prismaticism has
managed to just take that board down a
tick by poking in with the mechs. And
Pedro was like, "Yep, that's kind of
what I wanted. Actually, I want to draw
some more cards and further my
advancement of this game that way
instead. And now prismaticism is having
a little poke there at Hall of Legends,
which I'm imagine is going to have a bit
more push back.
>> Yeah, it might. But also, Pedro can just
say okay. At this point, is not
threatening to win. uh if they can cause
some favorable trades. I think Pedro
might just be fine with it even if they
uh you know are able to use a hidden
card. Yeah, Pedro says just that. Says,
"Yeah, let's just let this happen."
>> Now, Kaiser, you can go on in next.
Everyone's forming an orderly line to go
and have a look in the Hall of Legends.
>> Yep.
>> Uh
>> and there it is. Guards.
>> And there they are. Here they come.
We're going to Yep. Weapons master
equip.
>> Yes,
>> BF sword
>> indeed.
>> That is big. And it looks like I am
imagining that was just looking at the
top cards of the deck to see what they
were going to draw. But that is going to
be it. Game number one going to Pedro
with Azir.
>> Azir showing that numbers do matter.
Every single sand soldier was so
fearsome and it is because it's like a
build your own army. It really is being
able to put those building blocks
together and make the perfect scenario
from scratch.
>> Absolutely. And we see the sideboards
here. Face Breaker, another possible
card that can come in as a sideboard
option. Salvage probably not going to be
doing it. Call the week could be decent
though. Generally not great against the
deck. Not great against decks that have
a lot of small units. Not great against
decks that have ferris 4runner and well
Annie has both.
>> Defy maybe. Defy, I think, definitely is
an option there as of course the a lot
more combat tricks in this deck than you
would see in others. But Thermo Beam
definitely being a big one that Prismat
might want to bring in.
>> Yeah, Thermmo Beam, even factory recall
just putting all of that extensive gear
disruption into the deck to prevent them
from being able to continue. And I think
that's it. We could have carried on with
that game, right? Or we can say, I'm
going to look at those cards. Yeah, now
I'm losing this. Uh I'm going to just
forfeit that and I'm going to side deck
now so that I have a better chance of
winning. I'm going to save my mental uh
arithmetic skills for in a minute. I
don't want to get worn out. I need a
little break. And then also uh I'm gonna
get that side decking all done nicely.
And it's it's an important factor
between these games doing your side
decking. And it's a skill that I think
makes a pro player shine. I think it's
genuinely one of the most tough skills
to learn in Riftbound. knowing not only
what cards to put in your sideboard, but
also knowing how to change those between
matchups for which matchup and how
likely you are to see those cards as
well.
>> Right. It absolutely is. And again, we
talked about it. don't know that both of
these players have they certainly I can
say with almost 100% certainty neither
of these players has tested against this
each other's decks as much as they did
for a lot of the other decks in this
event. These are both relative underdogs
in terms of tournaments uh in terms of
this tournament the deck at least. So
certainly uh not the most easy Oh, yep.
I know exactly I know exactly what my
Annie or my Azir matchup is. is not
necessarily that as we take a look at
the trophy at that blade of the ruin
king. Beautiful trophy card and playmat
there in the middle of the stage. This
is what these players are playing for
and it is absolutely gorgeous.
>> I love the way they present that card as
well. It's not just giving you a little
card in a sleeve. It's No, this is the
champion card. That is a prestigious
trophy in and of itself,
>> right? It's just the one thing I found
with that card is that it's really hard
to shuffle into your deck. It is in the
case. And I'm definitely not taking it
out. So,
>> no,
>> I don't know what I do. I have to like
call it judge or something or I you
know, I'll figure that out when I win a
a regional qualifier. I'll figure out
what to do with the trophy case and the
card I definitely want to play in my
deck.
>> Definitely. Yes. You'll have to figure
that one out on the fly. But for now,
our competitors are both just inches
away from that trophy and those prizes,
but still in the fray of trying to earn
them for themselves as our crowd out
there. I see some familiar faces and we
are all so excited to be here. We've got
the bustling in the hall already.
Everyone is genuinely buzzed right now.
and excited to see who's going to take
the crown. We're in top four right now
at the regional qualifier in Le.
>> Yep, absolutely. As the players are
finishing up a sideboarding here,
finalizing those sideboards. You know, I
think even if you had a game plan into
Azir as Prisma and even if you had a
game plan into Annie as Pedro, I don't
necessarily know that those notes that
you had from before this tournament
apply to this very game. That's because
I think both of these players are such
high level that you really can't
necessarily say that, oh, this is how I
thought this matchup was going to play
out where both players sort of turn into
this pseudo control hold deck and I'm
just building up resources into one big
attack. I don't know if that's how the
matchup is drawn out. It happened in
that game and I imagine that both
players were on the same wavelength for
how that played out. But that may
actually be changing what they are
trying to do going into this next game.
>> I imagine both players were kind of
making mental notes throughout that game
to think about how the next one's going
to go based on their opponent's play
style. Because even if I'm prepared,
let's play say I'm playing Azir and I'm
like, "Oh, I know my Annie matchup."
Well, do I know my Annie matchup when
it's Annie Aggro with Rengar with Rexi
with, you know, extra flash and cleaves?
Like, do I know it? No. No, I don't
because that isn't maybe something that
I've prepared prepared for this exact
deck list, but also an incredible player
playing that deck list and also someone
who can remember how I played in game
one, adapt and play in game two. And
that's why we've seen a lot of these
games go to um a third game is because
people learn, adapt, and then bring that
into another match. And that's exactly
how these guys grow is that they learn
from every single
>> showdown.
>> Yeah. And I certainly uh only have the
Downwell Annie matchup uh sideboard
notes ready. So I I I'd be in I'd be
completely out of sorts here. I I
practiced against the wrong Annie. I
practiced against the meme deck instead
of the real deck. But uh no, I certainly
even if you're of course testing against
the, you know, quote unquote default
Annie, I don't even know what you would
consider that. I mean, at this point,
you would consider it what Prismat is
playing right now. But that's because of
this event, not necessarily going into
this event was everyone on a list like
this. So certainly new ground. Certainly
really a fun place to be in the world of
Riftbound in this this whole new set 2.5
meta.
>> It's a wonderful place to be. I'm I'm
enjoying my time here. I hope you are
too.
>> Our Annie and Azia match up. We had Hall
of Legends and Sea of Power for game
one. I'm curious of which battlefield
each player will pick next. I don't
think they have any No, they don't have
any overlapping. So, we're not going to
see the same ones come out. But, I'm not
seeing any kind of I don't think any of
the battlefields
for either of them feel bad for either
of them?
>> No, not at all. Well, I think that, you
know, Arena's greatest and Zon Warren
are relatively similar depending on who
is going first. I think if if Prismat is
going first, he's likely going to go
Arena's greatest. So, I would think that
he's likely on that for this game. And
then Trafarian War Camp is not bad for
Annie, but it's certainly a bit better
for
uh for Azir. And then Ceda Power of
course is in both their decks. So seed
of power is almost a completely neutral
battlefield as both players are bringing
it. But let's see. It looks like the
players have shuffled up and presented
as we are getting in to game number two.
Azir, Emperor of Sands versus Annie
Darkchild. Pedro versus Prismaticism.
>> Looking like an interesting starting
hand there. We've got seat of power and
the arena greatest. Like I said, we're
not going to have a matching, but we did
have one from a previous round. We've
got that seat of power back again. I
wonder if we're going to be fighting
over who's sitting in that this time.
>> Yep, absolutely. So, the game is going
to start off with both players at one
point here
and guards.
>> Thank you. I was like, it wasn't I'm not
practiced enough. But they won't they
won't come if I ask.
>> We're eventually going to get the whole
crowd yelling guards when guards gets
played. I know that's going to happen.
>> Maybe I'll give it a go next time. We've
got a tide turner of course.
Prismaticism just starting off that
rampage going up to two points nice and
early on.
Let's see if they can play anything
else. Just the Kaiser and passing. And
of course from that fantastic ability,
we are going to have two stills standing
at the end regardless.
>> Yeah, when you play it in the in the way
that Prismat does, it just looks like
the Kai'Sa only costs two energy and you
go, how in the world is this?
>> That was so cheap. What's going on? It's
like, no, no, no, no, no. Don't worry.
>> So good.
>> We've got the on guard here going in to
try to take out that tide turner, get
that second point of the game. And now,
is this something that Prismat wants to
fight over? not necessarily fight over.
Wants to protect that tide turner. Keep
that material alive.
And that's going to be a point there for
Pedro. That is another sand soldier from
the eye of our good friend Herold. And
looks like that might be a pass of the
turn.
>> Both players accelerating into two
points each already. Feels like we only
just started and already right into the
thick of it. Prismaticism making great
use of that timing. Hopefully being able
to outpace Pedro this time. If Pedro
doesn't have enough time to build up
those sand soldiers, then prismaticisms
might will be overwhelming in
comparison.
>> Yeah, absolutely. now needs to see what
do does Prismat think that Pedro might
have. It's a it's a lone sand soldier at
two, but does not want to send the
Kai'Sa into battle. It just wants to
take a trade. And are we setting up camp
again? Is the 4Runner going to go and
try to protect that Kai'Sa? We shall
see. Looks like the answer is yes.
>> We have a winner. Absolutely correct.
Ferris Born Runner once again being just
the chunkiest unit you could ever
imagine. And even when it gets taken
down, then more little guys just spawn
up in your base and you get two three
power mech tokens which basically if you
smash them together. It's another Ferris
4runner.
>> Yeah, he's not chunky. He's just big big
meched. He's he's got big mechs.
>> We've got the BF sword and guess what?
We're gonna give that a sand soldier.
>> Yeah,
>> because you get a sand soldier and you
get a sand soldier, but only if you have
a gear. And then then more gear gets a
sand soldier.
>> Yeah, it's I get a sand soldier and I
get a sand soldier and I get a sand.
Yeah, it's only it's only Pedro. There's
no sand soldiers for prismaticism in
this case.
>> Oh, that would be a twist.
>> Yes, you mentioned all of those gear on
the side of Pedro, but that is a thermo
beam in the hand of Prismatic. may be
coming down on a key turn, but in this
case it is just a development of a Kaisa
in the backline, a Noxis hopeful on that
seat of power. We are in this hold game.
And in this case, Chris is actually
ahead on the point tempo here getting
that fourth point before Pedro does.
>> Pedro is now going to need to really amp
up the pace. We do we have the resources
to do so this early on. We do have a
fair few sand soldiers. We've got two
gear in play thus far, but not a lot
going on in the hand, unfortunately.
Wow, that's not looking great. Couple of
discipline and and a rise. We've got
kind of spells that can help us in
combat, but nothing that can help us
make more sand soldiers other than our
uh champion uh unit and then our legend
ability.
>> Yeah, we I mean, we could cash in the
Arise now just to make a bunch of units,
but again,
>> it's only two, right? Yeah, it's it's
not a lot. It's not super great right
now. I mean, this is a uh a common issue
with the Azir deck is the other half of
deck problem where it really wants to
draw a pretty even mix of spells and
equipment, but if you draw all of one or
the other, it really does start to hurt.
And it looks like that is a little bit
what Pedro has run into here, run into
in this case, but is still able to
develop the Azir in past the turn.
>> Still a very respectable turn. Lots of
units going on there. We managed to get
recruit. We got Azir. We have still
control of our battlefield. So, not
going bad, but there's a lot of might
going on on Prismat's board right now.
And it's going to start getting a little
fishy when we jump into combat.
>> Yeah. And I'm wondering if this is this
the turn that we fire off a thermmo beam
to try to get rid of those equipment. I
think it there's a pretty you can have a
pretty good read that there aren't more
equipment in hand. Almost certainly any
one that they would have had would have
been played last turn with a sand
soldier as well. It seems quite unlikely
that they would have opted not to play
that and and instead play the Azir. So I
think you can get the read that there
aren't any equipment. So if you're able
to resolve a thermmo beam here, that may
be the all the equipment that Azir has
for the rest of the game.
That could be genuinely terrifying
having that arise in hand and then
having your equipment burned away by a
thermop. Oh, that would be awful. But
again, it's knowing those tells and it's
it's whether the timing is right. Do we
get into combat? We're on five points,
so we've got to kind of keep pushing
ahead. We've got a little while to go
yet before we can call a win. So, we've
at least got a couple more turns of this
game to go. Yeah, we're certainly in the
tank here for Prismat deciding is this
time to to fire off the thermal beam?
Should I wait until a later turn? What
happens if they arise next turn? Does it
matter? I think these are all the things
that we are talking about here as
Prismat and really seeing how many cards
are in hand. That's to figure out, you
know, what kind of combat tricks do they
have? What's the chance they have a
defy? What are the chance, you know,
wind wall? Something like that. is a
card that uh can certainly stop the
thermo beam and there are two in the
sideboard. So certainly in the range of
cards that could be in Pedro's hand. How
bad is it if a thermmo beam gets
windwald?
This these are all the questions that
are being asked by Prismat to himself
right now.
>> You've got to you've got to take
everything into consideration because
the timing is key. We've got about two
more turns before this could potentially
be all over before this could be a
victory for Prismat. So really every
single card needs to be played with
conviction.
Yeah, there needs to be a purpose for
all of them.
There is that Nox is hopeful. We've got
a gust which can be quite good. Better
off in combat though if you can use it
as a surprise and really just figuring
out what is the game plan. How do we
execute it and what tools do we need to
be able to execute it? We've got a lot
of might and base. We could go ahead and
challenge the other battlefield one.
There isn't a lot kind of going on. We
could potentially start to pick units
apart and then go for thermo beam when
the we kind of just have already
dismantled. Maybe Pedro won't worry
about sand soldiers being taken out
before the beam. So if you take out some
sand soldiers, Pedro might not react and
just be like, "Yeah, okay. I'll save my
resources. They can go cuz I can arise
them." Then thermo beam the equipment
and then oopsy daisy,
>> no sand,
>> right? No sand whatsoever. And no
followup sand either. But it's it's not
even just a matter of do I want to play
these cards this turn. It's a matter of
what order do I do them in? When do I do
them in relation to attacking? What can
I try to bait out? What am I looking to
bait out? Am I going to be able to?
These are all things that Prismat is
considering. And the consideration is
led to all three of the units in base at
the very least being picked up and
examined by Prismat.
>> Very methodical player.
>> Might stamp their way into the arena
greatest. But first up, we're going to
bring Annie in from our champion zone.
We're going to flash.
>> Oh,
flash to try to get the units at the
seed of power back into base. Are we
making a complete alpha attack right
now?
>> It might be. Honestly, it might be
trying to bring them back and just
overwhelm, take down as many units as
possible and keep Pedro on the back
foot. The way that Pedro won last game
was just being overwhelming with the
amount of units. And I guess if we can
limit that, then how's he going to
string together a similar win,
>> right? This is another one of those
plays where like the chances that I make
the the line that Prismat made here, it
it's got to be close to 0% that I'm
making this play. So, it's either genius
or it is crazy or it certainly could be
both. And I think that we've got a
little bit of all categories here with
Prismat. And we're starting with the
Ferris 4Runner coming in and wanting to
trade off for some sand here.
>> This is one of the mechanics that I
really love about Riftbound. Combat
isn't a stage. Combat is whenever you
would like to invite one of your ready
units into a battlefield. You can have
multiple instances of showdowns instead
of a combat phase, which I really enjoy.
I think it's a really great way to do a
combat style where we're having a
showdown every single time a unit
chooses to go in there on a separate
occasion. discipline comes in to
chunkify the might on Azir's side and
make it a little bit tougher. But I
don't know if Ferris Warunner
necessarily Yeah. was was going in with
the intention of taking them all out. It
was just so that they knew which sand
soldier was sticking around.
>> Yep. Absolutely. Wanted to keep the
equipment still on the battlefield, I
think, is the the biggest thing here.
And now we're probably looking to push
in with more units. Um the pump spell
that we've used will remain the
discipline. Uh but any damage done kind
of goes away. Put a plaster on and then
they're ready for the next time that
units come on in to say hey.
>> Absolutely. Now Prismat deciding do they
want to attack here? How much are they
going to attack? How many, you know,
onguards or disciplines are they willing
to play around here? They attack with
just two Kaisers, a single pump spell
stops that. If they attack with the Nox
is hopeful, that covers a wide range.
And if they attack with all of these
units, that probably covers most of it
if I had to guess.
>> I would say so.
>> Are we going back to defend?
The choices are genuinely
the most difficult that I have seen
across our series so far this weekend
here in Le. It is top four. We got to be
playing to our best. Another discipline.
This sand soldier is humongous for for a
sand soldier. I should should say up to
9 to 14. So, we're going to take both
Kai'Sa and then allow that sand soldier
to crumble.
>> The little sand soldier that could take
out two Kaisers is the story of that
combat, but we do get to that sixth
point there for Prismat. Not a ton of
resources on the side of Pedro, but you
know, this is a bit scary. There's
there's nine might left in the back of
the battle or of the back of the base
here for Prismat. Six left. Almost
stranded on that arena's greatest. So,
they are able to potentially threaten to
win next turn, but are they going to
have enough might to actually do so?
>> We'll have to see whether Pedro is going
to put up enough of a fight
with these remaining units to stop
Prismat from taking that win. We're now
playing not to lose. We need to make
sure that we're at least putting up some
units in that top battlefield.
>> Absolutely. We see that arising. Now we
see a good amount of equipment here on
the side of Pedro. A lot of energy as
well. So they could potentially have
multiple equipments played plus an
arise. And that is really going to put
quite a few sand soldiers into play. But
yeah, I think for the most part Prismat
is is willing uh is willing to take this
sacrifice here. They are going to try to
win on the back swing. Don't necessarily
need to stop this attack right here.
Whether they choose to stop this attack
could be the pivotal point. The thermo
beam comes down.
>> Oh, there it is. Of course, thermo beam
coming out. But there is death grip
coming in.
>> Going to be used in response to keep
that might onto a unit.
>> Transfer the might from one unit to
another.
>> So, the might sticks around. The the
gear still goes. Those have been fizzled
with the thermo beam. This recruit did
have the extra now to take down the tide
turner that moved in.
>> Yeah. And absolutely massive. I mean
that happens before the arise that is in
hand. Now of course there are still more
equipment
>> on.
We're going to have to play that eye cuz
we need to start rebuilding the board
now. Can't let Prisma just take the game
next turn. So we're going to need to
start rebuilding from here. We do have
two ready units. So, you know, we can
just sneak into both battlefields, but
is that going to be enough? No,
>> not right now. It certainly isn't. But
is it going to be about can they get two
battlefields here and then also be able
to defend against the nine might on the
side of Prismat plus any other
shenanigans that they may have from
hand? Of course, we know there are
Rengars, there are cleaves, there are a
lot of other units as well potentially
or other combat tricks as well that can
be quite scary. We're going to draw a
card from the seat of power and go from
there.
>> See all of the options available to us
this turn. See what we can use to
further our cause to protect our units
so that we're able to win on our next
turn. Both players at this point are
going to be trying to not only score
points for themselves, but also stop one
another.
>> Absolutely.
Looking to stop one another for sure. I
mean, again, it's it's it's about
getting to those even point swings, but
when your opponent has gotten there
first, you need to be able to stop your
opponent from winning. And now we are,
looks like we are spreading the love
here. Going to have a couple of
battlefields with some amount of
defenses on them. We've got the Azir on
the one. We've got two recruits, not
sand soldiers on the other. We're going
to make another sand soldier here. Where
is that one going? going to stay in the
base actually
>> and move either herald on there. We had
brutalizer now on one of those recruits
and just building this board. I like
having the sand soldier in base as well.
It's kind of showing the intent for well
I can't win right now but if you manage
to deal with at least one of these
battlefields then I'm going to need
something to go into another one at some
point.
>> Y
>> going for a hidden card. Just debating
where. Okay, that's going to go on the
seat of power. Putting a nice cushion on
that seat, but a dangerous one for your
opponent, I imagine.
>> Yep. The hidden card could be a few
things. Could be hidden blade. It could
actually be a face breaker from the
sideboard, or it could be, and stay with
me, everyone. Guard.
>> Uh, not really sure which one it is, but
you know, I always like to take the
opportunity to to scream a card if I
can. We got a few units in the hand of
Prismat. I see a Noxis hopeful. I see a
Gust. I see what I believe is a hard
bargain and a traveling merchant. So,
those units are not really helping win
the combat here. The Gust may be able to
deal with a recruit
>> maybe. And then the hard bargain is
potentially doing something, but it's
not necessarily
that great against that much open energy
on the side of Pedro.
>> No, I think at this point when we're
Prismat, we're thinking, gosh, I wish I
could draw some more cards.
>> Absolutely. Nine might spread across
three units on the side of Prismatic.
Going to start with two mechs coming in.
And that is hidden blade on one of the
mechs. Now it is a risky proposition
>> to give Prismat two cards.
>> You got to draw some cards.
>> You got to draw cards. Ask and you shall
receive.
>> Which I guess one of the reasons you
might want to go in there is for exactly
that. It's like, well, if it is a hidden
blade and they do choose mine, then I
get some cards and that's pretty good.
>> Yeah. The problem is is it cost you it
cost you another mech to play that
unfortunately.
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Absolutely. Gusting
back the recruit with the brutalizer.
>> Yep, makes sense.
>> Get back there. Push, push, whoo.
>> Get out of here, please. And now looks
like Prismat is likely going to need to
>> might be saying a bit of a nope to that.
>> Yeah, looks like another death grip.
>> It's too big now.
>> It is too big. It's going to have to be
It would have to be a hard bargain
repeated here to stop it from happening.
Oh, we're going for it. That's exactly
what happened.
>> Hard bargain repeated is going to stop
that from happening, which means the
Gust will go through.
>> It got big, it got smaller again. And
Gust is the Gust was too strong. Put the
fan up to the next level. Crank it.
>> Yeah. The unfortunate thing for Prismat
is that this is all done just to not
lose.
>> Yeah, that feels bad.
running really low on units right now.
And we know who is better at making
units fast.
And then name begins with P and ends in
O, not M.
>> Yes, it is going to be a salvage
actually cast just to draw the card. Did
not draw anything there. So Annie
conquers. We're going to fortify with
the Noxis hopeful and pass the turn and
hope that this is enough to hold the
line here for Prismats.
Pedro also at seven. They're going to
have to hold here. It's going to have to
be enough. Pedro in an absolutely
pivotal moment here. needs to make the
right decision
and it's going to have to be soon.
>> Pedro must take the arena greatest
to get that final point for victory to
head forth
from top four here at the regional
qualifier in Leo. This is game two. The
pressure is on.
>> Yep. Here we go. We're going to start
with an ong guard. That is going to put
the
sand soldier up to three.
We equip a brutalizer.
>> That's a big soldier.
>> Yep. That will put it up to six, which
is not quite enough, but the seventh is
there with the soldier. And that is
Prismat drawing the cards. The fist bump
is extended. And we have an Azir going
to the finals.
>> Pedro has powerfully pummeled their way
into the finals as we see an Azir topple
our top four.
>> Wow. Again, Azir absolutely
playing I mean Pedro playing Azir to the
absolute maximum extent. I can say as
someone who tried to make Azir work
early on, I was not able to make it look
like that. Every time I played the deck,
I had no runes in play and no board
after a while. I traded everything off
and it ended up being inefficient. But
we see every single bit of value
extracted by Pedro able to take it down
there over a very strong player playing
a very strong and innovative deck in
Prismat with Annie. I'm honestly blown
away by both of these players and the
strategies they employed against each
other's very tricky decks. But seeing
the Azia go all the way in this
tournament has been a delight.
>> Yeah, it's been absolutely fantastic to
see a deck that has certainly not been
the top of the meta in Azir make it all
the way to the finals. certainly not
been a deck that has been on a lot of
people's minds uh going into or at least
pre-bands for sure. I think that the
loss of fight orflight has certainly
changed a ton here obviously for Azir
and it is paying off for Pedro in this
event.
>> Azir showing that you can build your own
army and make it work so beautifully.
And you're absolutely right. Sometimes
it takes the right player, the right
build, and not one of us trying to build
our silly deck and be like, "Oh
goodness. Um, ah, yeah, I've got all
spells or I've got all units. Why is
this not working?" Well, uh, I tell you
why it's not working. We're not Pedro.
>> Yeah, we are not playing it to the
absolute maximum. But, uh, Pedro has
done that, and we're going to be able to
see more of that in a bit. But Amy, I've
got some good news for you. We have
actually got game three of the other
match here in our top four. So, let's
see it. We have got Master Yi versus
Draven.
>> Let's see it boogie down with some of
the OGs. We've got Master Yi, Draven,
and here we go. Glorious Executioner
versus our Wu Bladesman. Who's going to
come out on top? Yep, we are here. We
are going to actually I was kidding
here, Amy. We are actually in at the
beginning of this match. I thought we
were going into game three. We actually
get the full match. This is amazing.
>> Oh, what a treat. Here we go.
>> I lied. No, this is game three. I'm You
know what? I'm gonna Maybe I'll say the
wrong thing again. We are in game three
here at the beginning of game three. We
start here with that sand soldier on the
side of Master Ye. Now we've got Draven
going into their first turn here.
>> You gave me such the emotional roller
coaster there.
>> I gave it to myself, too. So, we're
we're on this roller coaster together
saying go.
>> Incredible. Miy versus Draven. Whoever
goes through to the finals be facing off
against Azia. Both a fantastically
incredible player base. And what a
strategy you'd need to employ against
either of these to pull forth. We've got
our Trinity Force already on a Sand
Soldier. That's a great start if you're
Master Yi.
>> Yeah, definitely is. Of course, the
Trinity Force, a key card for Lucian,
but also in this Master Yi deck being
very very good to be able to threaten to
score two points by holding. That is one
of the downsides of having to hold is
you can only score one point. Well, you
can score two points if you are uh a
Trinity Force holder. And there we have
it. There's two points scored.
>> Bing bing.
>> Up and up we go with the Trinity Force.
>> Yeah, we could hear those points being
added there. And we've got a charm
bringing that Kaiser that was just
played forward bashing
into this sand soldier. An unexpected
twist that Kaiser wasn't ready for. Only
one Chaos Rune standing on CTCG's side.
So, we're cleaving.
>> Yeah, Cleave comes in and that does work
because Kai'Sa is turned into the
attacker, but there we have it on guard.
Going to counter that. So, that is a
Kai'Sa and a Cleave down.
>> We even got the Raven Bloom Conservatory
trigger though it did not actually get a
card, but that's okay. still gets to
happen there with the charm and the sand
soldier holding down the fort.
>> Holding on in there. We've just got a
pouty porro going into our turn. We do
get the hold point. So the porro's done
it job. But we got a falling star. Oh my
gosh.
>> What more so fast?
>> Oh, what I'm like, what more could you
ask for than a falling star being used
on a sand soldier? And it's so important
we're actually using a not so fast. So
strong.
>> We need that sad soldier. Kaiser coming
in again. Pouty porro going to come back
to base. Keep him safe with Kaiser.
>> Yep. Keep him safe. Not only do we not
want him on the battlefield, we also
want Kaiser to be able to conquer that
battlefield. That aspirin climb that we
are ever so importantly on this game,
which means we are playing to nine,
>> which means it is odd point totals.
There's another Wait, hold on. Did we
just see this? Is are we
>> No, it's a different art. It must be a
different turn.
>> Are you sure this is not deja vu? We
missed another Raven Bloom
>> conservatory trigger, but that's okay.
No cleave this time. The Kai'Sa is down.
The sand soldier has
>> has killed
multiple epics worth of legends. Now, I
think I wonder if this is lore accurate.
Has there ever been one sand soldier
holding a Trinity Force that kills
Kai'Sa twice in the lore? Does does that
sand soldier get like a promotion? Uh
when does he get to be above soldier?
>> Well, it does get a promotion to getting
rebuked. So now this sand soldier has
eaten two Kais has now also eaten four
runes on the side of the Draven. I don't
know if there's ever been a sand soldier
that has done as much as that one right
there.
>> That did a lot of damage. Not in
physical might, but just damage to our
opponent's result.
>> And scored five points as well.
>> I scored five points.
Nah, he deserves a promotion.
>> I think so. I I would agree. That sand
soldier did a lot of work there.
>> Draven showboat coming to show off some
stuff. Show off some power.
>> Show off the might cuz it is Draven
time. And there we have the camel
himself,
>> the ruin runner.
>> You got to love him. You got to hate
him, but you love him if you're Sean.
Yeah, absolutely love him if you are
Shawn here. But Draven is going to be
conquering that aspirants climb. Pipor
wondering if they're going to stay
there. Is Powyp Porro worth a Raven
Bloom Conservatory proc is the question.
Don't
>> Oh, Porro gave us the answer. You're so
pouty.
>> Or we could also have a Ferris
forerunner there as well.
>> Oh, it's the alliteration squad over
there. Potty Porro, Ferris, Berrunner,
>> Ruin Runner, also alliteration. Yeah,
it's it's all there.
>> Yeah, we're going in there. Hiding a
card. It's not there.
>> It's not there. It can't hurt you.
>> I can't see it.
>> It definitely can hurt you. Yes.
>> Nope. Camouflage. So good. So good.
>> Absolutely. And we see the Ruin Runner
at five.
The other side, of course, we have eight
on both battlefields.
I say
>> on guard coming in on the Ferris
4Runner.
>> Put him up to seven.
>> That's not Ferris forrunner. You silly
>> ruin runner. It's one of the runners.
>> It's a runner.
>> Runner.
>> Different runner. But whether it's
Ferris or Ruin, we're running away from
combat here if possible. And it looks
like it is no longer Draven time as the
fair. No, the ruin runner. I almost said
that again. as the ruin runner
>> is taking down the Draven. But actually,
it is Tide Turner
>> there to swap over and save the Draven.
Saving the Draven.
>> Tie Turner here being like, "No, not the
showboat."
>> Oh, absolutely.
And as we see here, we can have the ruin
runner
>> up to six points if you're Sean. That is
a demanding position to be in. Now it is
our turn. If you're Draven, you got to
stop him. You got to try and deal with
that Ruin Runner. The only unit on the
other side of the board so far.
>> Yeah. And that's fine, though. You You
really don't mind if that's the only
unit you have. If that's the one that
you have, it is massive. It is seven on
the base, but when it defends alone,
it's going to go up to nine. Plus,
there's a couple of cards in hand and a
lot of energy on the side here of Sha.
So, they are going to be in a pretty
decent position to try to defend here.
But, you know, Draven does not really
have much of a choice but to try to
contest this because they're going to be
getting two points and going up to eight
on this next turn.
>> Don't like that.
>> Not enough to win right now because of
Aspirin's climb, but still is a great
spot to be in. It's pretty scary when
that Trinity Force comes into play and
again just bolsters you into the
commanding position, especially when
we're going to nine points. You've kind
of put your opponent on the back foot
because they can gain fewer points per
turn than you can.
>> Yeah, absolutely. When you are holding
and you only get one point, well, it's
not great when your opponent is also
holding and they get two points. That's
just that's just basic math that even I
can do.
>> One is bigger than two. Turns out that
is the case. We are moving Draven
Showboat back. Wonder if we're going to
be doing something this turn with him or
if we are waiting to set up a def or a
an attack for next turn. We shall see.
How much of an attack is it going to be?
Rexi in the backline
>> and a porro.
>> And a porro. So now we're going to go up
to eight. So technically we could be
threatening lethal here if we're able to
take that Raven Bloom Conservatory. We
have the mastery key in the chosen
champion zone. What do we have? And is
it going to be enough or are we just
going to play defense here?
>> Up to eight points using that two is
greater than one. Trinity Force giving
us an extra hold point there. Now we
just need to take that top battlefield.
But wait a minute, there's no units in
base.
There are no units in base, but we do
have a Ruin Runner in base now. And
there's a first mate.
>> Incredible. Readying the Ruin Runner, so
they can dash right in.
>> Yep, they can dash right in. That is
going to be a discipline. Going up 9 to
eight. We see one energy spent. It is a
stack deck. I don't know what we can
see.
>> There was two ferris 4runner. So,
they're not going to be very helpful.
>> That's going to be it. The handshake is
extended. We have Master Ye in the
finals. No Draven. That is absolutely
insane.
>> This is not the League of Draven as Sha
strikes gold for victory with Master Ye.
Our finals will be Master Yi versus
Azir. Azir has already taken down a
Master Yi in our top eight.
>> Can they repeat that or will it be a
Master Yi victory this time round?
>> Yeah, and I mean not all Master Y are
built the same. I know I uh talked to
both of these players in the finals.
Actually, weirdly enough, these are two
of the players that I interviewed in the
finals here, and they both had different
uh different opinions necessarily on
this matchup. So, again, this is
certainly not the finals that we were
expecting. I don't think anyone predict
I did not see a single person predict
this finals. Master Yi versus Azir. Show
me the receipts if you did. I will like
your comment at the very least uh and
say, "Great Photoshop skills, buddy." Uh
but cuz I do not believe that. But this
is absolutely spectacular. I'm so happy
that we got the chance to see this. Amy,
>> I'm so overjoyed. Not only that we got
to see this, but we got to feature that
last game there. We got to feature that
winning moment. We got to see the joy
that came from finally defeating Draven
and putting them in the top four, not
the finals of this event.
>> Yeah, Aurelia. There were three Aurelia
in this top eight.
zero in the top four. They all flopped.
No, no offense to the players. I know.
Did very well. Long day, but very much
very much. Here we can see here is the
final bracket. The road of Bedro, the
road of Sha. Here, Azir versus Master
Ye. No Aelia is here. No more Dravens.
We have got the calm legends in the
finals.
>> They're calm and collected and they have
earned their spot by battling so
tremendously throughout this event.
>> Yeah, absolutely insane top four there.
But Amy, we've got so much more here.
We've got the finals coming up, but
before that, we've got a video with
barcode
>> Domino who just won the best of set
medal cars. Congratulations. How do you
feel?
>> I feel amazing. I was waiting if I'm
going to get it or no because at the end
it came down to tiebreers and I managed
to stay on top.
>> But that's absolutely incredible. To be
honest, I was walking down the alleys
and I saw you during the entire
tournament. you're in the top tables and
I was like, "Wow, he's doing that with
set. You're a true set master."
>> Yeah. I started the tournament very
well. I went 9-1 and then I suddenly
lost all my last three games, but hope
luckily it was enough.
>> Exactly. I mean, in the end, you still
had the medal card, which is great. What
does it mean for you to have this card
because in the end you are the best set
of the room.
>> Yeah, I mean it feels amazing. It's my
second set after Bologna.
That is absolutely insane. I mean, right
now you are literally the best set of
the world.
>> You can say that.
>> So, what's next now? Do you plan on
still playing set for the next
tournaments or do you want to put your
eyes on another champion, another
legend?
>> I'll probably play set for as long as
it's possible.
>> That is the mindset actually. Once
again, congratulations. Back to you
guys.
It's time for the finals. Loar, we are
ready. Ready for our second ever RQ
finals in Europe. And these are not the
decks I think for a finals we would have
put money on uh to begin the weekend but
as we've seen play progress I think ever
so slightly people have thought okay ye
definitely up there as starting to to
get up the wins as well.
>> I think we have to start a uncomfortable
conversation about
>> is green the best color in the game in
the game.
>> So what you're saying is we need bands
we need
>> that's what I meant. I I I think I will
say though that um through a lot of
Spirit Forge uh many people were saying
well chaos is clearly clearly the best
uh single domain. Um
>> it was the most popular color in this
event.
>> It was it was and certainly has had a
lot of impact and and that's not to say
that the bands have completely removed
chaos from the the the the trophy uh you
know the
>> we had five that incorporated purple
color in the top eight. And that's why
it's a surprise not to have a chaos deck
in the finals.
>> Mhm. It is. But at the same time, if you
were an avid, let's say, uh, uh, viewer
of people's content or opinions for pro
players, you could see that many people
were leaning towards either yellow color
decks, you know, or mid-range Master E
was something that was under radar a
little bit. But if you are nowhere, you
knew that midridge master might actually
perform in the tournament. And it did.
Having two of them in the top eight is
actually quite incredible. And now we're
going to have an aer versus a master
final. That is that is probably the
least
I would expect from another final when
it coming to this regional.
>> That's a very fair statement when you
come to as we said number of decks
played in the room there. Both of these
were not within the top three decks
represented, but definitely uh very
strong performances throughout uh the
tournament so far. We can talk a little
bit about both players roads to the
final. Uh Pedro the uh the top seed
coming out of Swiss uh was able to take
their road through the top eight and uh
you know side selection has been key. We
saw that first match up for them uh
really put the pressure on actually
winning this exact matchup earlier,
right? It was the the Azir into the E
having side selection really punished
his opponent.
>> So, we can draw a little bit of like
parallels between those matchups that we
already seen. Like for example, what you
mentioned because he's a higher seed, he
will choose to go first in the first
game, right? And then will most likely
go if will he win the first one, loses
the second one, then he will go first
again in the first the third match. But
what we already established if you were
not watching the top eight match uh for
um for Pedro over here there have there
are two locations two battlefields that
are just so pivotal for uh the for the
Azir legend when they especially put it
against the master Yi and one of them is
Trifiran War camp which will allow the
Azir to stack that battlefield and deal
an insane amount of might on that one
battlefield that the mastery will have
problem into conquering All right. And
the other one is Hall of Legends, which
Azir can use to create more might
essentially by creating more tokens
while the Master Yi can like essentially
only use it if the other battlefield is
going to be forge of the fluff and
that's still like very clunky to like
and almost improbable to use actually
twice in one turn.
>> Both of those battlefields uh were
really quite oppressive in the the wins
for uh Pedro on Azir over on the other
side of the table. Um, you know, coming
into this on the Master Eye, we
obviously saw
the game where basically like turn two
was Trinity Force off um, Forge of the
Fluff that his opponent had played,
which was crazy, and then playing like
double Trinity Force jumping up through
the points. So, um, yeah, it's been
quite a battlefield dependent day in a
way, which sounds really strange, but
you know, we were a little bit stuck in
a rut of seeing a lot of Dreaming Tree,
obvious
that that sure they have impact on the
game, but not quite in the way that that
we've seen asymmetrical impact with some
of these battlefields.
>> Yeah, you could say that, for example,
the dreaming tree in most games would
have been symmetrical because both of
the decks have spells that are targeting
a unit, right? and it can be down during
one showdown which is not something that
for example seat of power is a good
example. seat of power only is
triggerable when concurring and not many
decks can actually conquer or like hold
and conquer the two battlefields at the
same time or it is happening in like
more pivotal moments of the game rather
than just during every turn and while
some decks are actually capable of doing
that almost every turn like Rexi like
Azir typically like yellow decks right
so then you have those kind of more
asymmetrical effects that you said and
they can have a bigger impact on the
game which I feel like is neat as Well,
because it it gives um deck building a
little bit more depth as well, but at
the same time, it creates more uneven
situations on the board, which might not
be the best for like the viewer
experience or like the chance of like
specifically the disparity between going
first and going second gets even bigger
when the battlefields have bigger effect
on the game as well.
>> Yeah, we are only a few minutes away
from our finals. Of course, have to give
the players a moment or two in between
rounds here. They are the final two
people in the room playing Riftbound
within the main tournament. I I actually
saw some people still out playing
Riftbound. We've got a great audience as
well in the hall. A couple people just
jamming games. They're like, I've got
the stream on. I'm going to jam some
games. That is like a good evening.
>> Exactly. The atmosphere here in the
venue has been great all weekend. If you
haven't been able to make it to RQ Leil,
please try and join us in RQ Utre coming
up next for Europe or if you're across
the pond. Uh see you next weekend. RQ
Atlanta. Sadly, I won't see you there in
person, but I know uh our our colleagues
over on the broadcast team there will
walk you through all of the action for
sure what is sure to be a great event,
and we'll have to see whether the meta
read is the same over in North America
as it has been here in Europe. I'm not
starting that banter. We're not going
there. I mean, we could talk about the
potential impact of this meta game for
Atlanta because I feel like
>> because of the aspect that equipment
equipment is getting so much traction,
uh, I think it could be something that
will affect the meta kit.
>> Could very well. Well, there is a big
question on which deck is the best this
weekend. Let's get in to our finals.
All right, this is it. After two days of
competition, of heated battles and
clutch moments, it all comes down to
this. Two players, one stage, one title
on the line. For the two players, this
is more than just a game. This is real
competition. This is legacy. This is
everything they've worked for. The first
player coming from Spain playing Azir
Pedro
and his opponent coming from Germany and
playing Mastery Sean.
And for the last time of the
competition, I'm going to hand it over
to our wonderful commentators,
James Lawler. take it away.
>> Thank you so much, Barcode, for bringing
us into the finals here in Leil. That's
everything on the road to the finals out
of the way. We've got all of the
housekeeping done. The players are on
stage. They are ready to get into the
game. And so am I. I'm so ready to go.
>> Yeah, I'm actually kind of like, you
know, pacing in my chair cuz I cannot
wait to watch the match. It's going to
be, you know, maybe not going to be the
fastest because I'll be honest with you,
if I will be sitting in that chair and I
know that I have no time limit to play
the game and I'm playing for the first
place in a regional qualifier, I will be
taking my time when it comes to taking
every single decision. But of course,
>> there's not going to be a slow play. You
still have to make a reasonable decision
in time even when there's no, you know,
time limit in general. But what one
thing I will tell you though, I feel
like there's a very high ceiling with
the Azir deck and it seems like the
players who are actually putting the
hours and the reps and they have the
planning in their heads like ahead of
time like two turns ahead, three turns
ahead. It the deck completely works in a
different manner than what we typically
would expect from an Azir deck. And it's
showcasing how complex and beautiful
this can this game can be when you have
masters of the decks. and and that is
now the second tournament in a row for
Europe that we're having where it has
been a deck that requires expertise and
reps. Uh Allan on Ezreal last event over
in Bolognia showed us that, you know,
playing however many hundreds to
thousands of games on on Ezreal and
drilling that strategy again and again
can lead you to a win compared to here
now with Azia being the uh the deck
we're looking at with that of course has
some complexity to it. Mastery as well
is not one to uh count out as this is
the deck list here for Pedro Azia,
Emperor of the Sands, based mainly
around equipment and generating sand
soldiers and very small units in order
to actually control the battlefields and
win. Of course, very unit light. Uh just
the chosen champion really coming into
this from the main board at least.
>> Yeah. And then we have also the Vu
Blazemen. A very classic deck coming in
from even set one when mid-range G was
also an option in addition to the
Aurora, but now establishing it himself
in the metag game as the prime choice
when it comes to the overall deck
archetype that comes into the metag
game. So we're going to have just, you
know, some amount of units that try to
conquer and hold a battlefield after
that. So kind of similar to what um Azir
wants to achieve as well. But the stark
contrast here is that Azir has explosive
turns has really like a lot of
possibilities when it comes to the
swapping the might between units by
equipping it and then juggling the
equipping the equipment between two
units going one by one into battle, but
also death gripping a unit to then
transfer the same might that you will
double from the equipment on the same
unit in the same turn. So potentially
creating a really powerful unit at the
same time, you know. So there is the
difference. I also like the um the
change in game plan for Pedro that he
presented in the previous time when he
played against Master Yi. It was one of
the theories that we we talked about
where Azir typically wants to play wide
and use the sand soldiers weapon masters
to not pay for the equip cost. But at
the same time, when you play against a
master, you're going to have to have a
bigger unit. Yes,
>> that will go over the top over the
defenses and make sure that you can
utilize your equipment to the max by
stacking it on one soldier. But then you
have to pay the rune cost which will
keep you down on potential like
explosive turns with Arise as well. So
there's there is payoff and there's but
there's also the cost. So that's one of
these skills that you have to have when
you play a deck that is a little bit
more complex like Azir. And also just
wanted to point out Pedro didn't lose a
game yet.
>> A whole match. He's undefeated.
>> Undefeated in matches. Sha has only lost
the one match and tied one as well. We
are into game one of our finals. It is
Hall of Legends for Pedro. Sha will be
on Vilemore layer. Vilemore's layer. So
we are in a situation where you know
that does remove some of Azir's potency
of being able to move battlefield to
battlefield as we see the opening
mulligans here. Mhm. Now the the mulan
for year has a guardian angel and aas
and if I'm missing was that also a
discipline. Let's see what will start
with desert's call to open the game. So
no equipment this time.
>> Yeah it's not quite the uh the eye of
the herald
>> but that's for tranar war camp. That's
like open for travan war camp for hall
of legends going to be important to have
an equipment next to him to trigger the
hall of legends. untap your legend and
get two sense soldiers.
>> And I feel like you got to feel okay
about this when your opponent just plays
a Zagnas as something to do with uh the
energy early on in turn one.
>> Mhm.
>> Again, not
too versed in the Master Yi matchup, but
that definitely feels like a card where
you're like, well, I'm just kind of
making sure I'm using my resources that
I can if I haven't got a two drop or a
turn one play.
>> Correct. And now we're going to have a
brutalizer being played. We are going to
equip it to one of the scent soldiers is
in the base. So that's the weapon master
use without any power cost.
>> Now for mastery, let's take a look. I
don't think um we established that there
are no
>> cool the weeks in the main for Azir.
Yep.
>> So you don't have to worry about a cool
week when you have one big unit on the
board till it gets to game two and
three. And that's still a question if
even is being sideboarded in. um that
changes the patterns with how you play.
Like if you're not certain what the
opponent's deck has and we have full
knowledge of the deck list when you're
playing into it will change with how you
perceive the matchup and how you play
the matchup. You can take take
completely different um completely
different ideas on how to execute your
game plan. So, the move to Hall of
Legends to score the second point uh the
third point, sorry, I should say from
Pedro. And that will be the Azir just
played into the base. I mean, you always
have to to look at is that something
that can be charmed away? Is there
enough potentially if Lenovo Scout moves
over to one battlefield? Is it enough to
uh to be able to pull that Azir away?
because we've seen the Azia be a big
finish for the uh at least the Azia
sovereign be the big finish for the Azia
deck.
>> If if you can remove that, that may very
well take out some of the potency to
close. So right now Sha is in a position
where he has to choose which battlefield
he wants to attack. Even if he wants to
attack, maybe he wants to like reinforce
his base and then move at the same time
when the opponent might be a little bit
lower on runes. But that I feel like
that moment might pass very soon because
right now Pedro has only two runes open
which essentially gives it like a
potential death grip a discipline. So
maybe an enuard doubleing guard is
possible but it's very unlikely because
only two
>> it is a discipline. So there's a
discipline. It's now 524
and the ball is in Sha's court to decide
if he has away. And he has discipline
against discipline and we're hoping for
a very disciplined finals from both
players. And so far so good on that.
That is going to be uh the Novori scout
conquering. Now where do we go? I think
there was a charm in hand. And having
used the discipline, this could be an
opportunity. You've burned the remaining
resources available from the Azir. So
the shields are down uh compared to
other times. Here comes the charm. Going
to remove the Azir. Very clear move
here. Moving Azir sovereign guards comes
out
and that is going to
>> be played in response cuz it can be at
reaction speed.
>> Can be a reaction speed
>> cuz it was from hidden.
>> It was the charm was targeting the Azir
in the correct. Correct.
>> Yes. But Azir of course will be declared
as an attacker here.
>> Mhm. So, is there a way of overcoming
the N'vori? Because the N'vori is also
going to get plus two, right? I'm just
wondering was there any way because the
brutalizer will get weapon mastered onto
the new sand soldier that would come
from guards, be brought with the Azir in
the attack because of the attack trigger
and would overwhelm the Novori. Defy
says, "No, get out of here with that."
So that was the line of thinking from
Pedro there to try and
>> it could have been a very good attempt
at breaking this charm, but
unfortunately the defy puts a dot at
that eye.
>> It does indeed. Find your center being
found early on in the game just to uh
advance the economy here from Sha to
just say, "Yep, I just going to stay
high up on runes the further we go."
Again, Shawn is trying to just use every
single rune that he can in this early
game to just say, "Okay, later I will
have better cards to use with my
economy."
>> But it was a very nice attempt of the
gods play and the possible movement with
the Azir Sover. Unfortunately, didn't
work out. It was It would be a cool clip
as well.
>> I know the Shar Shuffle would have been
kind of like really surprised you bring
him with bring the army with him. So,
that was a significant moment in this
game.
>> Yeah. Uh now it would actually break the
tempo completely for Shaun as well if
that would happen. So not only it would
achieve the hold as well. So we it could
have been a huge swing but that's not
the case. And now Pedro needs to rebuild
his board. We have seen an arise in his
hand. So his game plan right now is
going to be to do what he would
typically like to do anyway. So play as
many equipment and just
>> play them out.
>> Play them out and then go with uh with
the rides. And we know that there's no
windw wall in game one because that can
only be sideboarded by Sha and No, no,
sorry. Sha doesn't even play um the Wind
Wall. The Wind Wall is actually in Azir.
>> Yeah. Yeah, we actually uh we have them
backwards on our deck on on our desk. Uh
so some big power units here for Sha.
That will be the Master from the Chosen
Champion Zone. Only one rune available
for a follow-up here if this mastery
does go aggressive. And it's a one-way
trip into Vilemore. Vilemore's layer
here.
>> Well, not exactly. He does have ganking.
>> Oh, yeah. That is such an important part
of this card that is there. If you have
to move over to Hall of Legends, that is
absolutely
>> not a defy. Oh my.
>> Another
two defies are just absolutely
backbreaking.
>> Face breaker, more like back breaker
from Sha as the defy on two key cards.
And in the matchup earlier, Pedro on the
play was able to dictate the pace
against Master Yi. And in this game, Sha
has been able to control the entire game
around these showdowns on his own terms.
>> Yeah, it's really huge influence here on
this those defies. Those two plays were
establishing control for Pedrol, but
were completely denied. And not going to
lie, the guards play was also very cool.
But now we have to probably use the uh
uh reinforcements as soon as possible
because otherwise we're going to have a
problem with this ganking E. The reason
why the Navaris card went back to base
is because it's not needed anymore.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> You have the ganking E that is a little
bit stronger, right? And it will have
your unit in base for reinforcements as
well.
>> That Zas is still active as well.
remember. So when this guardian angel is
played, the Arise is likely to follow.
There's a question mark
in the way that I'm saying this cuz it's
are you going to just overwhelm the Yei
alone with one unit, which you probably
can with the brutalizer if you want to
equip that.
>> To be fair, I wouldn't be surprised if
Petro doesn't maybe wants to slow down
the game. There was alo possibility like
he's ahead on points.
>> He might give his opponent like the
possibility of going to five if he just
doesn't concur. builds up in the back
and just waits for the next turn. But in
this case, we are putting one of the
sand soldiers to get the points. We're
ahead on five. And now we're going to
maybe reposition the BF from the
battlefield. But it's still I think it's
still valid to keep it because five
versus four on the
>> would be nice, but the problem is that
the Master actually has six. So that
would force you to interact with it
first.
>> Yeah. So Massi, do you get the BF sword
back anyway with Massi having to kill
this unit?
>> But you would have to pay the cost then.
>> Yeah, that that is fair.
>> And here we're just building a huge unit
that is going to attack into the master
Y. This is going to be 9 to 8
>> and Sha has nothing available, no uh no
energy available to play around that. So
this is what you said earlier about
stacking all of the equipment on one
soldier. They are now at Vmor's layer.
So depending on how this how long this
sand soldier stays around here from all
of this equipment is now stuck.
>> Well, there is one out that is death
grip that can the unit.
>> Yeah.
>> Transfer all of this might to someone
else and then re-equip it. So when you
think about it, we I don't think we have
the death grip in hand unfortunately.
>> But if you have the death grip, that's
plus seven on another sand soldier.
reaction speed, by the way, which is
very important in in general, not maybe
in this matchup, but overall in many
match matchups, the buff on the reaction
speed actually matters a lot because it
can save you from removal as well that
is dam damage based or like play around
ghast and stuff like that. But also,
this plus five from this equipment can
be then utilized on someone else. It's
actually going to be plus seven because
brutalizer re-equipped gives you another
plus two. So, you're going to be able to
transfer essentially 12 might with one
death grip to someone else.
>> There's a white flame protector in hand
for Sha.
>> First time we actually see it being
drawn for on stream in in the games
we've cast. Yeah, we didn't actually see
it. Um, and of course that is a big
swing of might for the turn that it is
played. But is is that enough? cuz you
know as much as the the the micro
decisions perhaps went to Sha with some
cool defies and plays it hasn't broken
the tempo that Pedro has had. You you
mentioned it earlier like Pedro was
ahead on points and is now at six and we
are going to eight in this game. There
is no reason to be playing longer than
that. No aspirants climb or anything
like that. So really Pedro is
representing lethal with what is on
board. Of course Sha will be able to at
least break the sand soldier that is on
its own at Hall of Legends. You can see
how important was the arise to actually
bring in back possibility of attacking
and being proactive in the same turn.
>> Yeah, exactly. The follow-up turn does
have three sand soldiers even if Pedro
loses both battlefields. So that isn't
avoid scout conquering. Shan goes to
four. So Pedro does know he has another
turn at least save for a Trinity Force
shenanigan which
to stick in this match. But it is in the
deck. So we've always got to always got
to keep that in mind.
>> Typically would like to keep that
protector in hand when you gank with the
E
>> to potentially finish a game, you know,
like but it
>> sometimes has to be used just as a
discipline essentially in this scenario.
>> That is the really big discipline.
>> There is the white flame protector
field. Yeah.
>> Which is a big unit on its own. White
flame protector of course eight might.
You're paying a lot for it, but it is
going to give plus eight might to
another unit the turn that it enters.
And I wonder where that eight might is
going. Surprise. It goes on the Master
Y. And Master Y now a very very big E.
14 to 7 seems like a
pretty easy matchup for the Master Yi.
But now, how much might do we have? Oh,
right. There was a guardian angel.
>> Yeah, Guardian Angel. So, uh, it does
get recalled back to base. Right. We
call the sand soldier. Right.
>> All the equipment does stay on it. That
is the other point.
>> Now, let's take a look at the hand. We
have a death. Is that death grip?
>> It is a death grip. It is. It
>> is a death grip.
>> At least one. I think it might be two
actually. Yeah, it is two death grips in
hand. So, that is significant, right?
Cuz you can
>> that you can quad triple the amount of
might essentially
>> and Sha is tapped out.
>> There's no interaction over here. Yeah.
So, death grip from one is going to put
all of that might onto the second. And
then you can equip the brutalizer and
the BF sword. And cuz you don't need
runes cuz this game could end this.
>> We need we need eight for breaking
violence lair right now. This sand
soldier has plus five plus eight. Yeah,
he he can do it. How much is this?
>> Is this is 3 five six.
>> I'm going to let the judge at the mic
over here.
>> It's enough. And that means
transferred now with the second death
>> just to another unit and Shan has
nothing to do about it. Sean nods his
head knows exactly what is coming next
and that means it is likely to be game
one now going over to Pedro.
>> We re-equipped the BF sword. We've
re-equipped the the uh um brutalizer.
That's another plus six and it's attacks
and it's attack for million. It's over
9,000 over here going into holes of
legend and close out closed out this
game. Sha had two defies that seemed
clutch, but they weren't enough to deny
Pedro game one. And Pedro from being our
top player from Swiss has not lost a
series yet is now one game away from
being crowned a Q leal champion. You can
see how insane death group is. But when
you get two of that and you essentially
just
you just get so much value out of the
equipment, it's bonkers. Now, when it
comes to game two, we're going to have
reinforcements. Shan can side in the
actions. The actions can foil your plans
with like stealing a G8, which is
actually very impactful. Uh, stealing a
BF sword is also pretty huge because now
you're staring at a seven might action
that is most likely not an easy target
to kill to then reposition uh repos
repossess the the BF sword that was
stolen. And you've mentioned a couple of
times while we've watched the Master E
games. Thonk is another thing from the
sideboard where where you're playing
games against somebody that is stacking
one big unit. Think kind of just is
fight or flight at home in a way where
it just says, "Yeah, get out of the the
combat. No, you can't re-equip
everything because sure you you're not
going to lose the unit, but you can't
get those equipment on anything else to
utilize the might." And that is what our
players are playing for. This is what is
on the line. The trophy from RQ Leil,
the Blade of the Ruin King first place
champion promo and playmat. And wanted
to a little bit go back to the sideboard
things that you were mentioning. Two
actually an interesting card that you
mentioned because typically when you're
playing with closed closed deck list,
you would not consider maybe starting in
Twunk against an Azir against a in
theory a white deck. But you see how
Pedro is actually playing the game, how
he's swapping his game plan against the
Master here. And Tonk seems to be now
enticing because you know that that that
Pedro will try to create this monster
soldier and one Tonk can also negate any
value of the death grips that are going
to be used on on like a particular push.
So Tonk might be a good sideed side um
card to go in. Action and defy is
something as well. pirate um sorry first
mate um can actually be also implemented
into this game plan because you will
need a little bit more proactiveness
with how aggressive the Azir is and you
have to be a little bit more on your
toes when it comes to just not letting
go of the battlefields.
>> Yes, thank you to everybody joining us
here in the venue. They are giving round
of applause over to our competitors or
themselves you know you deserve it too.
many of the competitors there joining us
in the hall as it is Pedro against Sha
at this point. Pedro is one game away
from being crowned RQ Leil champion. And
Shauna is going to have to go back to
back on these games, which uh again,
>> not easy.
>> Not easy. Especially when
>> even if you level up the series to one
and one, you then have to overcome
Pedro's advantage of going first
>> on Trafarian War camp.
>> Yeah, which is what we're expecting. We
would expect that is what we saw Pedro
do earlier in um a best of three against
the
>> makes so much sense.
>> That means his second uh choice was seed
of power, right?
and that's still a another battlefield
that will benefit more the Azir player
than the Master most likely.
>> Uh normally I I think we do have a
little bit of delay, but uh Pedro at
this moment has his headset off, so
not that our sideboarding is
particularly compared to them.
>> Yeah, if you've got to the the finals,
you probably are not caring about our
sideboard opinions. Um,
>> yeah, but there's a delay on on the
stage.
>> There is a delay on on the stage just
for integrity reasons. But those of you
at home that may be wondering, I think
it is worth us addressing it while it is
uh the elephant in the room on stream.
It has been a wonderful weekend though
of Rift Band. We had the bands come in a
couple weeks back uh really shake things
up. We uh were not sure exactly what to
expect, but we had a good read on the
top six decks, I think I would say, in
the meta. Some have not necessarily
lived up to the the hype, but Azia is
one of them, and Masi is the other as
they find their place in the finals. I
feel like Europe, we're get starting to
get these unorthodox finals like Ezreal
in the last uh Bolognia. Now we've got
uh Yei and Azir and we're on to game two
>> and it's going to have we're going to be
having Raven Bloom Conservatory which is
a deck sorry which is a battlefield that
can benefit both of those decks because
we know that Azir doesn't have a lot of
units. It's just equipment and spells.
So potentially holding the Raven Bloom
Sanctuary can be
>> a big target. That is not what Shawn
wanted to see in the Tasty Fay Folk for
the opening hand. I think
>> still can draw one more card.
>> Yes, still gets one more. I think Shawn
was looking for a a turn one play from
that mulligan, a find your center, and
another card. Okay, the turn one play is
Guardian Angel. So again, utilizing just
what you can at the beginning of the
game, but it is not ideal. Death Grip,
Hidden Blade, Eye of the Herald is the
one. Ah, this is exactly what Pedro
would be looking for is an early unit
and will end up passing.
>> Yeah. And now he can control the Raven
Bloom Conservatory and because of that,
he's going to be able to potentially
draw more cards whenever being duled by
Sha's unit. So, this is actually quite
significant tempo loss in case of of
Sha's opening hand. And you can see it's
desperation as well a little bit because
this kind of play when action is just
being played as a two drop. Of course
the weapon master has a slight advantage
but the thing is
>> um Azir Pedro over here can read two
things from a play like this. Either one
is
>> his opponent has multiple actions in
hand and he just feels like he needs to
play some one of them to just play
something that is on curve this turn.
Right? or this hand is just so bad that
there are no absolute no other units.
Yeah.
>> And the only thing that is going to be
there is pure interaction.
>> That goes that gives you informations
that you can then implement into your
own game plan. And for Petro, that is
definitely something that he's thinking
about over here.
>> So where does Sha go from this moment?
Two disciplines. Ah, it's a lot of
combat tricks and not really enough way
of playing them. Axan's going to go into
the Raven Bloom. Blue. Not a draw. And
it goes to the bottom.
>> Okay. Is that how much information does
that give over that a BF sword is
getting moved out of the way? Here comes
a discipline.
>> We're buffing the sand soldier. Goes up
to four. And we
>> discipline in return.
>> We have five to seven. There's one more
energy open for Pedro, but Enuard is
only going to give us plus one because
of the recruit.
So, not even an option. Yeah, that is
the moment where it is less effective.
So, Axan will successfully conquer the
Raven Bloom Conservatory.
Now, four up for Sha. And now the
question is where does that go? First
mate comes in. Radies up.
>> Doesn't ready.
>> No, no. Yeah, I that is fair.
>> Maybe in the future that would actually
matter if the unit is ready or not. I
believe it's a mandatory trigger, but uh
that is it. If you're not choosing to
move Axan back, that is fine. I I you
know, these players are right in the
middle of a finals, but anyway, that is
not the uh important point of this game.
>> So now the big question is, do you ever
want to give your opponent potential
draws on this action and Raven Bloom
Conservatory or are we just taking over
the seed of power and making sure that
we are ahead on on point?
That is going to be interesting
development. I'm not sure what is
exactly in the hand apart from I feel
like one Doran shield.
There's the equip of the eye.
>> Going to take over the seed of power.
>> No card draw. You have to control the
other battlefield to um to have a draw
from the seed of power.
>> Yeah. And uh
there will be Azia played from the
chosen champion zone.
We're equipping the order eye. And now
we're going to have a potential charm
play because it's only one energy open,
right? So if there's a defy, that defile
will be drawn out as soon as possible.
Oh, a hidden card also being placed
already on seat of power to prevent a
potential push from the first. And
again, I wanted to reiterate um the hand
read from Pedro. Yeah. Could be really
big because he knows
>> because of the turn one play, because of
the turn two play being action, you are
most likely expecting a lot of potential
pushes with sorry, a lot of potential um
combat tricks that could affect this
decision when it comes to hiding a card
because this is a pure tempo play right
now and it's helping against a first um
punch first, first mate. And if it's a
face breaker, it will just absolutely
demolish that kind of play. Remember
though that all of those hidden cards,
so hidden blade, face breaker um can be
still defied.
>> Yes. Yeah, they can. So, here comes the
Trinity Force from Sha as uh that will
look to have that hold strategy
and see whether you can jump leapfrog
the way up from two points past Pedro
and potentially
take this game two of the series
as uh now Axan of course will need to
remain on that battlefield in order to
uh uh utilize that Trinity force.
Correct. But it's bringing it to a very
respectable hold. Seven by default and
plus two from the passive is actually a
very very big amount of might. Now the
thing is Pedro has the Azir Sovereign
that is capable of bringing all of the
tokens if he wishes to attack the other
battle. Of course that hidden blade,
sorry, not hidden blade, that hidden
card would have to be also played in
this case uh if you choose to bring all
of the units there. But now we see
reinforcements
>> swapping the positions of the sun
soldiers essentially and bringing in
more recruits to make the um hold on of
power a little bit bigger. We're
counting the might. So potential push
into the Raven Moon Conservatory, nine
on defense
for the action. And I'm not going to
lie, I'm not certain actually how much
Pedro has. It's four, six, eight. No,
that's an I. So that's seven, eight,
eight with the recruit. nine with
another recruit being spawned.
>> Okay. Uh so should be able
in fact because of the the Master Yi
defensive uh
ability that will mean that Axshan is
holding on nine, right? Um
>> it's kind of very interesting situation
because Pedro is ahead of points. Yeah.
>> And he's establishing his control over a
seat of power. So, if we just keep this
board in check and we're just not
allowing the uh Master Yi player to just
push over the seat of power, we do have
an advantage of a Pedro's position, but
he needs to think about the potential
play from Master in the upcoming one
where he can just play the master from
champion zone which is ready and then
push with it as well. Now, because of
the action in turn two, you might
account for like multiple uh
disciplines, multiple uh punch first.
And if you have two punch first most
likely available next turn, that is plus
10 if that hidden card is not phase
breaker,
>> right? There's so many interactions by
the way, because if it's a face breaker,
but if there's a defy and if there's
other interaction here, like it there's
so many complex interactions over here
that you have to go through because not
only Petro needs to plan out his own
turn now. He needs to set up a plan for
the followup from the Master Y. So, he
needs to think about how those energy
points will going to be used this turn.
How this amount of energy will be
affecting the amount of energy that
Shawn will have access to in the
follow-up. And how will that affect the
amount of pumps that can be utilized as
well?
>> You're the meme with like all of the the
lines drawn on the the board of of all
of information,
>> every option. Yeah, there there are so
so many options on this Azia deck and
being able to determine exactly which
one is the correct one has been key for
Pedro throughout this tournament. Of
course, has not lost a series so far.
Will go
aggressively into the battlefield. Of
course, all of those recruits do have to
be uh spawned onto the battlefield that
is attacking or you are attacking with
the
>> 14 to 9 14 to 9, which is by the way
perfectly to draw the might
>> with one punch first, right? So, one
punch first is enough to draw, but then
we have still under energy from Pedro to
play a pump.
>> The other option are there are two
disciplines and an on guard I think in
hand. I didn't see is there a punch
first at all? Well, I think it might
just be those three. There is a fourth
card. Oh, there is one I think in in the
back of the hand.
>> So, we start with the discipline
potentially
>> giving a new information. Sorry, rather
hiding information from Pedro,
>> right? Saying, "Oh, I don't have a
punch. There's a hidden blade."
>> So, he wants to do that probably before
the discipline is being resolved, not
defi potentially for a defy. Yeah, that
would be what you would be looking. nods
and says, "Yep, you can have the
discipline, have the draw, have the plus
two."
>> Small triggers, but they actually do
matter because one card less in the hand
is a smaller chance for having a defy.
>> There is first. Uh, so there's a few key
things here that can be used. There is
uh salvage, double death grip is uh
potentially huge as well to transfer
over that might. remember that um action
speed
>> punch first is not something that we can
stop with like you know with like
salvages and then digging for potent
like you cannot even defy it anyway.
>> Exactly.
>> Um I'm not sure if we would see wind
wall being sided in.
>> Yeah, I was wondering about that
>> pet roll because that is a card that
potentially could affect cards like
punch first but it would be in like
meaningful moments at the end of the
game and not in the midst state.
>> You're both dramping for that, right?
So, you know, it feels like economically
it's bad, but maybe it's like the last
twist of the knife to get over the line.
>> Literally, what happens with hidden
blades? Typically, you just don't care
about the card draw because it just to
finish up the game.
>> Salvage comes out. That'll take care of
the Trinity Force.
>> Mhm. Brings down the might
to wait, it was discipline and punch
first. That's seven. 11 with the status
from uh um might of action. And then we
have GH. That's 12. So, that's 14.
>> Tied at 14. We know there's an on guard
in hand for Sha. Haven't seen Pedro's
hand for for a couple of moments. And we
know there has been new information put
into the hand. So Sha basically has to
commit that on guard, right? You you you
have to say, "Yeah, I'm I'm all in on
this.
>> Out.
>> This is your tournament life in this
game. If you don't win this game, you
are out. It's a lonely power was the
other." And that Tasty Fay folk still in
hand. That's going to be an on guard.
Um, looks like Pedro lets it resolve.
Hidden blade directly onto the axan
says, "Yeah, you can have two cards
because I want the tournament."
>> That's so many cards that were just
completely like negated with that hidden
blade. It he does replenish the hand
with two cards, but losing the Raven
Bloom Sanctuary uh sorry, conservatory
will potentially also give card draw to
Pedro. Although I will tell you one
thing, this is not an ideal scenario for
Pedro because the plan was different.
The plan was to destroy the GA.
>> Yeah.
>> And then essentially winning this way
and having a a way to clear the action,
but once he committed because of the
might differential to destroy the
Trinity Force, that plan was gone. So
definitely not ideal on what happened
here. Uh but it does cost Sha a lot when
it comes to potential tempo. punch first
was two two power, right? So, he's
setting up himself to again uh how many
runes right now? Three, six, seven.
So, now we have a hold for 12 on board.
We have seven potentially musty goes to
13. And you you know that it's only one
orange rune as well. So, you know,
there's no punch first represented for
the next turn until Sha's uh next
channel phase.
>> What a brawl. That was such a complex
board state. Like,
>> yeah,
>> truly
>> lovely. Lovely. Really lovely.
>> Love a thinking board state.
>> And now we also have the hidden card,
which I I'll be honest with you, I can't
remember what it might be. Axan's going
to go in just checking the board state
before we confirm that showdown begins.
>> And it will trigger first the Brave.
>> The RA. Exactly. That's what we're we're
waiting on before that happens before we
know that this completes. You can see
Shawn doesn't actually complete the
beginning of the showdown. Um
doesn't actually
end up converting into a combat phase.
though this is going to be just the
first mate going over to the seed of
power for now.
>> Still ahead on points from Pedro and
he's going to go most likely five.
Seeing this kind of play, it will tell
me that it's going to be a pass. And
there is the um there is ruin runner.
>> Yeah. So this is likely setting up. Is
it even do you even play the tasty fay
folk accelerated on the next turn and
just try and go over the top of this
giant board stack? Although if you're
Pedro, do you just happily go to six if
possible here? uh looking at if there
was an arise in hand I believe right so
>> there was an arise in hand and you can
break the heat of power you can draw a
card bring everything back the question
is
>> is it worth to use the heat of power in
this moment how important what is the
closing of this game condition
>> you bring everything back from the Raven
Bloom conservatory you use
>> will you leave one recruit with that
hidden card I guess to your information
and still get the trigger from Raven
>> Bloom Yeah. And get everything else
back.
Maybe you arise here. If you have a
readyied unit that you can get an
equipment on, uh, like with to weapon
master something, take out the first
mate and then next turn go from six to
eight because the likelihood of Sha
being able to hold both battlefields
through Pedro's next turn is very slim.
>> Well, we also have to count how many
cars Shron has. I think it's four.
>> It's four. One of them is a tasty fo
>> and he's going to have access to how
many runes? Seven. Nine. All right. So,
nine runes is like master Y and to open
or
accelerated and uh one
>> will you even need it when you you will
not need it if the units are coming to
base because you can just take over
control.
>> Oh, yeah. Cuz you can just play it to
the battlefield. You're exactly right.
So, it would be folk plus two open. Uh
you don't necessarily need to
accelerate. Again, one of the decisions.
It all it all depends on what Pedro does
first. So, Pedro needs to plan out this
round uh this turn and we'll see what's
going to be the potential follow-up for
it.
>> Yeah, we uh Azia games do tend to have
some uh
>> there's a small army over here.
>> Wide board states at this point
>> and a pass. So, just chas was a pass. It
was a pass. So we're not also concurring
conquering seed of power.
>> I can understand Pedro wanting to be
cautious in this moment,
>> but is it more pressure to say I'm at
six?
>> Mhm.
>> I am in a position to overwhelm you.
Yeah, I I very much realize that. Uh, so
it is now up to Sha to say, "Okay, how
can I again put as much presence on the
board in order to try and get myself
back in this game?"
>> Remember, there were two death grips
again.
>> Yeah, that's a key point as well. So, if
maybe that's Pedro's strategy is say, I
can absorb your best shot.
>> I can take whatever you're going to give
this turn and then I'm fully in control.
Yeah, you you might actually see a a
turn without sorry a complete game with
an anorise if there will be just turns
when he will just deploy another piece
of equipment go for death grips easily
break the uh easily break the the
battlefields but at the same time
because he didn't go to six this game is
extended.
>> Yes. So it does probably just another
one point concur with like minimal
impact on on his runes um for the next
turn. Setting up a alpha strike for um
the turn after that when he's going to
be able Oh, there's a discipline draw
from the raven boom. That actually
changes a lot because now
>> you get two and it's another draw. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> And the the runes are there to play it.
So on guard comes through.
Looks like it
resolves. Although I'm I'm sure Pedro
will probably want to take a moment if
that discipline is likely to be played
or not.
>> We have guards which can re-equip one of
the equipments that is in the base. What
is it in the base? I think that's the
brutalizer.
>> It has a brutalizer which is plus five.
>> This is a huge swing. Typically when you
like calculate like how much might
someone can get from a a a card is not
plus five.
>> An extra plus five is uh is a lot.
Although Shawn did have that information
that there was a hidden card there, so
it was a possibility. You knew the
brutalizer was there. If you're
accounting for that, then uh you're a a
very uh you know fidious player at that
point of uh making sure you are doing
your due diligence on the board. What
does Shan have in hand in order to uh
pump this Ruin Runner potentially?
>> Well, the thing is what what do you do?
Do you punch first? You know, there's a
discipline in hand.
>> Yeah. So you go to 12, your opponent
goes to 13. Just by default, you will
need to have another card after that.
>> Are we just assigning damage
>> and there's a point? Yeah, just
assigning damage.
>> Oh, I I was wondering if
Yeah, at the the the showdown as well.
>> And that brutalizer still active for
this turn. So that sand soldier is uh
five might currently. You can see our
might track is at the bottom. Thank you
to the team that are controlling that
for our broadcast this weekend.
>> It's actually working very smooth. I
have to admit
>> with these confusing board states as
well. Um,
Trinity Force played at this point,
>> but still the discipline is there,
right? The discipline is there.
>> Yeah, the discipline is there there. So,
Trinity Force goes to the first mate. So
trying to build one big hold
potentially.
So that's five might. So goes up to
seven with the the Masi's passive.
>> We have it call setting up potentially a
base reinforcements.
Yeah. Is there a
>> for two for two? Yeah. is depends on
the defy.
>> Doesn't find it.
>> Desert's call will resolve.
>> You can see how important
>> was the defy for Pedro here for his game
plan. He's like saying, "Look, if I can
defy this, this is probably game
instantly on."
>> Yeah. Whereas now, this is the the thing
he holds to six. This is where the
question of was going to six on the last
turn
it like more pressure than than Sha
could cope with. is still in control.
Pedro is still in control of this game.
>> I I really love I have to go back to the
discipline in response this desert
score. This is a really heads up play
because it also shows how he's managing
his energy because he has the arise to
death grips in hand. He knows that the
death grips are going to be the things
that he's going to be using the most,
right? So potentially Arise and two
death grips if he wants to finish that
way. That is 10 energy. So he's not
going to have a use for the discipline.
So use it now, get a card,
>> or potentially get the Defy and do
something else. It's really nice
planning. I really love that.
>> Yeah. Now we'll uh see Pedro continue to
work the line out for what is the way
out. So Death Grip will unlock the
brutalizer for this turn.
>> Mhm. Transfer three might.
>> Transfer the might. Now you get to
re-equip if you're able to either weapon
master or just uh do it the oldfashioned
way of
>> Remember that the seed of power is seven
might.
>> Yes. uh at least it will be on the the
showdown on on the defense trigger
coming through. So that brutalizer is
now going to pump up that sand soldier
as there was a a brutalizer equipped by
the the rune floated.
Okay, we're going back
to the Raven Boom Conservatory and now
we're setting up an attack which should
be for eight 83.
I was uh
>> at this point I feel like full control
of the game has gone over to Pedro.
Another unit will join from the
equipment being played. The Azia Emperor
of the Sands Legend ability used to
create another Sand Soldier and another
problem for Sha to deal with. We are at
the winning point. next turn for Pedro
>> and it's 7 to4. That is such a big gap
to close. You're going to have to set up
now for Shan from Sha's perspective,
you're going to have to set up a
efficient enough attack to break the
hold from Pedro to deny him the win. But
not only that, then you have to set up
your own defenses in the same turn
>> against the potential arise double
conquer. That is a very hard task ahead
of Shawn. And let's see what are the
options for him.
>> Yeah. What does Shawn drawn into? Didn't
quite get a glimpse, but that is a bit
of a shake of the head. It doesn't look
>> positive for Sha in the reaction. We
know there's a Tasty Fay folk there.
That's not going to be enough to dig
Shawn out of this permanently uh and
take us to a game three. It does feel
like Pedro
>> is on the verge
>> of becoming RQ Le champion. don't have
full information on Sha's hand.
>> If he's going to pull it this off, this
is going to be a comeback like that.
We're going to definitely remember
>> I think
that is starting to enter the realms of
cope as Sha
>> Well, let's think about it.
>> It's not done. This is where untimed
both players can go deep into the tank.
>> Yeah. If there's any potential card draw
that Sha has in his in his hand,
>> that can also alter the decision making.
a discipline pre-attack could also be a
thing.
Four energy split, eight energy split
>> and you have to take out both
battlefields. So even justice sand
soldier at three tasty fay folk comes in
acceleration
only two energy for the defense
>> which is almost nothing.
>> That is looking rough. That's equipped
on a Trinity Force
>> eight might potentially going into the
seed of power I would say. Although
Raven Boom Conservatory is probably the
better.
>> You have to clear both. So do do you
have and I mean there's four runes
available for Pedro in this situation.
So there are a number of of uh abilities
that can dig Pedro out of even just a
combat where you're only exceeding by
one might or two. We know that there's
disciplines on guards. There's multiple
things available. And here we go. This
is the attack from Sha is going to send
the Faith Folk with one sand soldier,
leaving two units remaining,
Raven Bloom is going to reveal a rise
off the top. And that is another nail in
the coffin. Sha knows that even if
everything gets completed this turn,
even if Sha can turn the corner for now,
Pedro has options the following turn and
that has to be it.
Petra's thinking
five to 10. It would have to be quite a
lot of cards now being used to actually
defend this position, but I don't think
it's even worth it. Doesn't matter.
There's a death grip.
>> A death grip.
>> Death grip on the defending unit. And it
reinforces the seat of power to
reinforce the potential hold for the
win. We're getting plus two for the
order soldier going up to five
>> which means Axan and the the sand
soldier can break through. So Shawn has
broken the Raven Bloom Conservatory. Two
runes available for each player. And now
for Pedro and Shawn, it comes down to if
Sha goes in with both units and does not
have
equal
combat spells, it's a death grip
>> plus three on the unit.
>> That brings up
>> is it enough? Because Sean it would be
like discipline or yeah, punch first
would do it. If there was a discipline,
it would only even it. So it's not
enough because a rise would likely be
enough to conquer and break through the
tasty fay folk with the Azir on the next
turn. We know there's I think a
Stellicorn or a parro in hand. That's
not enough. Sha is going to sweep his
units from the board and that means
Pedro
>> is about to hold.
>> Is there anything that you can do for
two energy over here? Charmed to No,
that's
>> fist bump comes out. Perro undefeated
at Rul on Azia.
Congratulations Pedro on an impressive
win through the tournament on one of the
decks that we were wondering if it's
>> would it rise to the top? Would the
Emperor of the Sands become the Emperor
of Le?
>> That is for now. A quite amazing one.
Undefeated completely.
Devastating like this entire tournament.
Not losing a single match in this entire
round.
Very impressive run through the
tournament. A new champion of Europe has
been crowned for Pedro. Uh we will have
of course we will of course have a uh
championship crowning ceremony coming up
uh soon. You have to we we we can't just
end it there.
>> Winning the trophy. He's winning the
medal foil legend
>> and the playmat.
>> He's winning the playmat. He's winning
the champion uh the ruin king.
>> Can you imagine? You you turn up to your
Nexus Knights.
>> You sit down and you're like, "What do
you mean my opponent has like all of the
like the collectible items?"
>> He has the trophy in his like pocket
over here.
>> Just stands it. That's actually how he's
counting his uh points on the play.
Yeah, exactly. of the side. Uh I mean if
I could I would but uh never that is not
going to be the case as uh Pedro a force
to be reckoned with this weekend. We
will of course give Pedro his flowers as
we go through the the crowning ceremony.
But you know Shan I want to talk about a
second place finish on the master
respectable as well
>> will secure of course the best of Yei uh
metal cards. So very respectable, very
very well played to top not only top
eight but top two in one of these RQ
events means you are absolutely one of
the top tier players here in Europe.
>> Correct. Exactly. When you think about
it, you're the second place out of
almost 2,000 players competing in in in
Riftbound regional qualifier. Li, it's
an amazing achievement for everyone
who's competing here, but specifically
also for people who went into day 2,
finished top 64, finished top eight. All
those are bent like thresholds that you
go go and cross and you add to your
resume as a COD game player. And it's an
incredible achievement to be in the
finals of such a huge tournament.
>> Absolutely. And an honor to be in a
finals alongside you as well.
>> Hey, we made it.
>> Yeah, we made it. I was saying to people
earlier, 100% uh conversion rate for for
this tournament. So, I'll take that as I
told you before the the weekend, you're
you're going to make day two. You got
it. You made five. Congratulations.
Um, it has been a wonderful weekend. It
has really truly been uh our honor to
bring you the Rift Band action here from
RQ Leil. I mean, we've shaken up the
meta with bands. I think it is fair to
say that there is a variance to the meta
now. Even though some of the faces are
the same, the decks are quite different.
I would say that the top eight was wide,
surprising as well to some degree and
very enjoyable to watch. The game play
is so different as well. Like it
changed. Everything changed. There's
more, let's say, combat tricks being
used in general
>> and more combat in general. Like we had
a a long phase where Draven was like, I
don't really want to fight against it.
>> It's not even Draven. It's like a
reaver's row.
>> Yeah.
>> Like not without the reavers ro there's
no more interaction like going back and
reattacking
>> fight or flight. similar re rationale
there where you know a lot of the early
games of Spirit Forge were saying how do
we avoid combat avoid uh decks from
actually getting themselves stuck in and
scoring points and now now we have all
of those uh tasty combat phases to work
through Lothar any final words from you
on our
>> it was a pleasure to cast it was a
pleasure to watch as well when I was not
casting and the overall atmosphere of
this event was phenomenal
>> it has been our pleasure pleasure. My
pleasure and everybody's pleasure here
at RQ Leil. That's it from the casted
desk. It is time to crown our champion.
It has been an incredible journey and a
wonderful tournament, but in the end,
only one player could get crowned.
Please welcome your rebound regional
champion here in Liil Pedro.
Congratulations, Pedro. What a wonderful
game it was. It was absolutely insane,
to be honest. And I see that on your
face. Please tell us how you feel right
now. How does it feel to be crowned as a
champion?
>> I don't know. It's a feeling I I have
never had before. Yeah, it's insane to
go to defeated now to be here. I don't
know.
>> It actually feels insane when I watch
you. You're always smiling and it makes
sense. You were undefeated all the way
with only two draws and in the finals.
20 in the finals. That's a statement.
>> Yeah. Yeah. To be honest, I'm more
nervous now than I was before. I can't
believe it.
>> I get it. But it's not a problem because
you deserve to be crowned. And if you're
crowned, I mean, you deserve to leave
the trophy. So, why don't you do it?
Damn.
Guys, give it up for your champion,
Pedro.
One more time for you champion Pedro.
And that being said, I'm going to hand
it over to our wonderful commentators,
Bla. Amy, take it away.
Wow, what an absolutely spectacular end
to a spectacular event. Amy, the biggest
regional qualifier we have ever had.
Almost 2,000 players whittleled down to
one. And that was Pedro.
>> Pedro did a fantastic job. It was
elating to see his joy being our Le
Champion. The first ever Le Riftbound
regional qualifier champion.
>> Yeah. And and not only that, doing it
with a deck that I'll say very few very
few people would have actually picked as
a champion. I know a lot of people were
talking about new decks coming out in
the set 2.5. A lot of people talking
about how maybe Azir, maybe Rexi, maybe,
you know, another one of these decks
that's not just Aurelia or Draven are
doing well. Not a lot of people I saw
picking Azir as that number one. But
here we are at the end of the event
seeing a champion crowned and it was
Azir.
He believed. He's played Azir for a
while. And now the ultimate
glory has come straight to Azir now.
Showing that any deck, if you believe in
it and you craft it yourself, test those
matchups and come in with confidence and
pride, you can make enough sand soldiers
and win.
>> Yeah. And I think, you know, we didn't
we didn't get it in time for our matches
that we cast, but I think maybe next
week in uh in Atlanta that the
production will have that sand counter
ready. And I think they may need it
given the uh I'm going to say increased
uh the increased amount of azir that
we're definitely going to see in Atlanta
next week.
>> Oh yeah. Um you could even call it a
sand timer.
>> There's another idea for how it could
look.
You're welcome. You can have that one
for free.
>> Yeah, they came up with it only 10,000
years ago.
>> What a wonderful weekend. Thank you so
much for com commentating alongside me.
I've had so much fun and I'm certain
everyone at home has as well. It's been
a riveting story. We've had so many
moments. What's been your favorite? Oh,
you know, I I called it out early on in
the tournament and it has remained one
of my favorite moments of the event.
That double deny turn Azir on day one.
The figned. Oh, I definitely don't have
a second deny cuz I didn't deny your I
mean, it's just so good. Such good play.
But we saw that throughout the entire
time. I mean, one of my friends,
Prismat, ends up making it into the top
four. Their third top eight overall. I
mean, it's a huge moment for Prismat,
for Riftbound in general as we are
starting to see these multi-time
highlevel players come back and perform
at a very, very high level. So, I mean,
really, it it's hard to encapsulate one,
but those are certainly really high up
there for me. And of course, thank you
so much for carrying me this entire
week, and I felt so great and so honored
to be on the desk with you. But Amy,
what was your favorite moment of the
event? I honestly think being able to do
all the wonderful interviews with our
winners, I think that they provide such
incredible insight and they're really
key moments to learn more not just about
their decks but the game, how they
prepare and how these top level players
really come to be.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We are starting we are
continuing to see these players make a
name for themselves. We've seen it
across many RQs. We've seen it now here
at the largest regional qualifier that
we have seen. We of course next week
have Atlanta which is going to I mean
there are certainly people in America
right now I can imagine that are
furiously taking notes.
Oh boy, I need to be practicing the Azir
matchup. I need to be practicing the
Annie matchup. Throw this Aurelia match.
I don't need I don't need to worry about
that. They're not going to win in the
top eight. We didn't see a single one
win in the top eight. What's my Azir
matchup look like? What's my Annie
matchup look like? Give me more Crims of
Azir, please.
>> I tell you what, the most popular guy at
every single locals this week is going
to be that one Azir player. Whoever's
playing, you're going to be like, "Hey,
Helen, uh, you play Azir, right? I I
need some help. Can you help?" The most
popular people are going to be those
Azir players who have put the reps in
already this week. I
>> I do agree with that. However, I think
the most popular players at Nexusite are
going to be the people who have arises
in their trade binders right now because
everyone, myself included, traded those
off at the beginning of Spirit Forge. I
was never going to play Azir. It wasn't
going to happen. And then Pedro goes out
and wins the event with Azir, a deck I
thought I would never play. Absolutely
fantastic. Absolutely amazing for Pedro.
And I got to say, Amy, I mean, maybe
it's a coincidence, maybe not. Both of
the players in the finals I had winners
interviews with earlier on in the event.
Just saying if you have if you win your
match and you want to request an
interview, you got to request it with me
cuz maybe that will lead you to the
finals.
>> Maybe that's the key. Who knows? My guys
will went on to on to lose. But I think
a couple of them got best off. So
honestly, I'm super happy. Can't be too
mad about that.
>> Honestly, I'm so pleased that I got to
talk about sex some more with someone as
my favorite deck at the moment. And
again, it's given me a little bit of
hope. Although Azir did come out on top,
it's given me hope that actually I
should keep playing my favorite and I
should keep pushing on, making edits to
my deck, seeing how the meta forms out,
and actually I don't know my Azir
matchup, so I guess I better get
practicing, too.
>> Absolutely. Well, it is. It's a really
great point that you bring up because
it's not just, oh, I'm going to go for a
metal card, so I'm not going to play it
at my next play at a skirmish. I mean,
we saw Azir win the whole event. It
wasn't just for a metal card. I talked
to the the Ye players. They were saying
this is the best deck in the format
here. This is an absolutely high tier
deck. It is not that I'm just going for
a metal card. It's nice that there's
maybe the deck population is not too
high. Maybe I will get a metal card.
That's not what I'm entering this
tournament for. I am entering this
tournament to win the tournament. And we
saw Pedro do just that. A
>> phenomenal play, phenomenal moments.
We've made memories that will last
forever at this one. and memes that will
take us through to many a tournament.
>> Yeah,
>> I that is my goal if nothing else is to
when we see guards guards played on
camera, we've got to scream it in the
crowd. I think we can count on you to do
that in Atlanta. It's going to happen. I
cannot wait to see it. But we are in the
closing hours here as players are
leaving the event here. I mean, it's
just been such I know it's a sad time.
It's been a long weekend, but it has
been a fantastic weekend. And it is
really, like you said, Amy, it's going
to be one that I'm going to remember
forever.
>> And if you haven't been to a regional
qualifier before, you're missing out for
a start. But secondarily, there is much
more than just the main event. Even
spectators have so much to do. We've had
many events on that obviously we haven't
even been able to cover. We haven't been
able to tune into. We had the Super
Nexus night. You want to tell us about
that?
>> Absolutely. So, you like Nexus Knight,
you like prizes, you like bringing your
favorite deck to a giant community
event. That's the Super Nexus Knight. It
is an absolutely fantastic one to play
at a regional qualifier. You can, of
course, look up your events here. scan
that QR code to get information on local
nexus night, local summon summoner
skirmishes here. And honestly, that is a
really great tool that I've personally
used if I'm going to visit someplace or
if I'm like, I just want to go on a
little day trip here. Are there going to
be riftbound events that I can actually
travel to? A lot of times there are,
even where I'm in, which is in central
Scotland, there are stores all over the
place that are running Nexites is really
fun to go to.
>> Honestly, guilty. I'm going on vacation
next weekend and I won't pretend that I
didn't have a little look if there was
an Nexus night that I could have done
while I'm there.
>> Yes, it's absolutely fantastic. But like
you said, there's so much to do at a
regional qualifier. Again, we're biased,
but I got to say, if you can make it to
a regional qualifier, you absolutely
should. Is just so much fun. Whether
you're playing in the main, whether
you're playing side events, whether
you're playing the big events, whether
you're coming here and just hang out
with friends and playing. There's a free
play area that is literally full the
entire day. You can go up, find people
to play with, find people to trade with.
There's vendors here. There's just so
much to do at an RQ. And it it's really
like there's something there for
everyone. It's really an amazing
experience. I think some of our
cosplayers put it best in one of the
barcode interviews that it feels like a
mini Riftbound League of Legends
convention. There's so much more than
just the main event. We only can show
you guys a snippet because otherwise
we'd be here all week,
>> right? Yeah, it it would I mean it would
be crazy to cover the pre-regional
tournament, but it would be kind of
cool. I mean, we were all of us casters
were out there, you know, birding the
top tables to see, hey, what is going to
be played because we want to see what
might be uh played at the uh at the top
tables in the main event. And we saw
decent amount of of of Azir, a decent
amount of Rex eye, of course, we saw a
lot of Aurelia, we saw a lot of Draven,
a lot more Draven than we saw in the top
game. Just saying. Uh but, you know,
decks like Annie didn't really see
didn't see a ton of Lucian, though. did
actually see quite a decent amount on
day two. And that's another thing I
completely forgot. I think I didn't get
this stat confirmed, but I'm pretty sure
it's true. This event had the most
diversity of number of legends,
different legends in day two, which is
kind of crazy.
>> It's not every event that we've seen
every single legend day two in this
event. Not every single deck did, but we
saw quite a few of them do it. And
honestly, could we really ask for
anything more? Could we ask for better?
>> No. It's absolutely
wondrous to be able to see so many
different legends, so many different
play styles, and so many different
people. This was our largest regional
qualifier yet, and I have no doubt
they're just going to get bigger and
bigger from here.
>> Yeah, they absolutely are. I mean, we've
had some behind the scenes. We've been
talking to people. We've been hearing
the chatter, and everyone says the same
thing. We want these events to be
bigger. We want them to be better. And
that involves you showing up to them and
having a lot of fun because that's the
best way. I mean, it's word of mouth,
right? Obviously, we're going to talk on
the broadcast about how great the events
are. I'm saying I mean, you ask me at an
event, I will tell you how great it is,
how much fun I'm having. But really,
it's people that have gone to events
that come back to the local game stores
like,
>> "Bro, it was so fun. And like I got I
got the you know I I farmed uh events
and I got this metal prize card. I play
I won my Super Nexus night. I I met a
bunch of new people. Did you know that
the people at the other store also went
I didn't even know they were
competitive. I thought they just played
multiplayer. Yeah. No, everyone was
there. It was a huge thing. I was on the
bus over here and there was an entire
bus of players from all around and
groups of people like 10 plus people in
a group coming in on the bus over just
for Riftbound for this event. It was
absolutely fantastic to see. It's also
when you're on public transport or when
you're waiting in the airport or the
train station and you see people dotted
around on tables trying to find space to
play some games and test and you're like
it's kind of like play spot the
riftbound player as you're going through
you're like oh I must be in the right
place because there's game there's game
there's game there's game.
>> Yeah. And it's also like when you start
getting on the uh when you start getting
on the planes or the public transport to
get here, however you get here, you
start seeing backpacks. Like that
backpack looks a little full and I don't
know that you're a student and it do I
see riffbound stickers? Okay. I think I
see riffbound stickers and different
tags on there. I know that that's a
riper. I know that's a gamer. And they
are going to the RQ. But Amy, I think
this is nearing the end here. It has
been an absolutely fantastic event.
Again, I got to thank you personally for
casting with me today. Any last words
for yourself here, Amy?
>> Thank you everyone for making this an
unforgettable experience. You all remain
in our hearts and memories.
>> Yep, absolutely. We've got a short video
here to end it off, but for Amy, for the
entire crew here at Regional Qualifier
Le, I've been Blevens and we'll see you
on the next one.
>> You never see this coming
to the
champions
of a world that we divide.
I saw the rain on the view of height.
Can we all
fight at the last
Heat. Hey, Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat up
here.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.